Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Pritlaff und ich begrüße euch hier zur Ausgabe Nummer 137.
Und ja, nach fünf Monaten wollte ich hier nochmal ein Thema aufgreifen,
was wir eben vor fünf Monaten hier das erste Mal besprochen haben,
nämlich die Situation in Serbien.
Und ich freue mich sehr, darüber wieder mit Dejan sprechen zu können. Hallo Dejan.
Einen wunderschönen guten Morgen.
Ja, wir hatten das Thema aufgegriffen, weil es seit dem 1.
November oder seit November letzten Jahres anhaltende Proteste gibt in Serbien
und das ist auch immer noch so der Fall, kleiner Spoiler.
Ja, deswegen greifen wir das auch nochmal auf und wir sind auch aus zahlreichen
Richtungen gebeten worden, das Thema hier weiterhin zu befassen und das tun wir damit hier auch.
Genau, vielleicht wer jetzt noch nicht die erste Sendung dazu gehört hat,
dann kann ich durchaus empfehlen, ein bisschen zurückzuspulen,
weil wir da vor allem auch erstmal so ein bisschen, ich würde sagen,
erstmal den Kontext aufgemacht haben.
So Serbien, was ist da jetzt eigentlich die Realität und was ist so der Hintergrund,
dass diese ganzen Proteste ausgebrochen sind.
Das wollen wir heute nicht alles wiederholen, sondern mal ein bisschen mehr
oder weniger chronologisch anknüpfen an das, was wir bereits erzählt haben und
daran vielleicht auch mal festmachen,
was sich in dem ganzen Komplex dann auch neu ergeben hat und wie sich das so entwickelt.
Es sind übrigens genau 150 Tage, seitdem wir die Sendung veröffentlicht haben,
die jetzt vergangen sind.
Ja, genau. Du wohnst in Deutschland,
du bist halt Deutscher, du bist auch mit einer serbischen Staatsbürgerschaft
ausgestattet, bist ja in der demokratischen Bildung unterwegs und verfolgst
das Ganze sozusagen ein bisschen aus der Ferne.
Auch sprichst natürlich die
Sprache und von daher hast du einen ganz anderen Einblick als wir alle.
Genau, und das tust du ja auch weiterhin, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Absolut richtig. Das heißt, ich habe, wenn ich ehrlich bin, sogar in den letzten
Monaten meine Kommunikation nochmal erhöht, weil ich dann eben das Gefühl hatte,
es ist notwendig und auch die Rückmeldung bekommen habe, dass die Leute einfach
dann doch dankbar waren,
Einblicke zu bekommen in Dinge, die da passieren.
Und ich habe für mich festgestellt, wenn ich einfach ein bisschen mehr nochmal
drüber schreibe, dass einfach das besser erfasst und verstanden werden kann
und ich an manchen Stellen vielleicht nicht ganz so viel erklären muss und ich
so auch zum Beispiel bei Trades irgendwie aufbauen kann oder auf die verweisen
kann, die ich schon mal hatte.
Das heißt, dieses Dokumentieren von Ereignissen hat mir doch mal einfach geholfen,
zum einen besser zu verstehen, was so passiert.
Aber auch, dass ich mir ehrlich bin, es ist alles, was da passiert,
beobachte ich immer auch mit der Perspektive, wie du gesagt hast,
aus der deutschen Perspektive.
Das heißt, was heißt das jetzt für die Gesellschaft hier?
Was heißt für die Gesellschaft in anderen Ländern? Was kann man davon übertragen?
Was ist denn gut oder was gelingt denn? Wieso gelingt das?
Wie kann man vielleicht sowas auch irgendwie erfolgreich in Deutschland umsetzen?
Welche Faktoren müssen wir hier irgendwie modifizieren?
Wie sind die Rahmenbedingungen? Das heißt, es sind viele Fragen,
die mich zeitgleich beschäftigen, wenn ich dann Sachen beobachte,
die in Serbien stattfinden.
Ja, und es ist gar nicht so einfach, da einen Überblick zu bekommen,
wenn man nicht irgendjemanden hat, der da ermittelt.
Ich habe dann jetzt, als klar war es, dass wir uns jetzt hier nochmal zusammenfinden,
zusammenfinden, dachte ich mir so, naja, da gibt es doch bestimmt auf Wikipedia
eine Timeline, wie das so bei
oft so vielen Krisen so ist, also Ukraine-Krieg, da kriegt man also die,
ausführlichsten Chronologien geliefert und das ist immer wieder wunderbar und
dann habe ich halt mal ein bisschen geschaut und deutsche Wikipedia war irgendwie
quasi gar nichts, also es gibt da zwar einen Artikel zu den Protesten,
aber mehr als, dass die generell irgendwann mal angefangen haben und irgendwie
wahrscheinlich auch noch,
laufen, kriegt man da nicht raus, dachte ich mir, okay, gut,
dann vielleicht englische Wikipedia, das war dann aber auch noch sehr dünn.
Da dachte ich mir, okay, naja, auf Serbisch wird ja dann vielleicht was zu haben
sein. Bin dann auf die serbische Wikipedia gewechselt.
Da war dann in der Tat ein sehr, sehr, sehr langer Artikel.
Konnte ich natürlich erstmal nicht lesen. Hab dann mir Google Translate geschnappt
und bin dann mal so ein bisschen durchgegangen.
Und nachdem ich so ein paar Absätze gelesen habe, kam ich irgendwie dann doch
sehr ins Grübeln und dachte mir so, das liest sich nicht wie ein Wikipedia Artikel irgendwie.
Also das hatte schon so ein bisschen was von Regierungsverlautbarung.
Was ist denn da los?
Ja, es ist so, dass ich täglich mehrere Stunden, würde ich sogar behaupten,
mir Podcasts und Nachrichten durchlese, anhöre, um so ein bisschen zu erfassen,
was so zwischen den Zahlen passiert, was das nicht in den Hauptnachrichten schafft.
Und in einem dieser Podcasts oder Folgen, die ich irgendwo gehört habe,
ging es auch ein bisschen um Wikipedia.
Und ich muss zugeben, ich habe mich da jetzt nicht so massiv beschäftigt,
aber als er es gesagt hat, ist mir dann aufgefallen, dass eben die serbische
Wikipedia zumindest viele Menschen, die regimennah sind,
wohl da Berichte schreiben.
Das heißt, das, was jetzt Kritik an einem Regime sein könnte,
da sehr dürftig irgendwie festgehalten wird und dementsprechend die Wikipedia
jetzt in Serbien, glaube ich, nicht verglichen werden kann mit der Deutschen.
Nicht, dass die deutsche Wikipedia und andere Wikipedien irgendwie deutlich,
deutlich irgendwie, also super wären, sagen wir mal so, super wären,
aber sie sind auf jeden Fall deutlich besser als das, was in Serbien vorliegt.
Das heißt, ich möchte jetzt, weil ich weiß, manche WikipedianerInnen werden
jetzt zuhören und wahrscheinlich dann irgendwie dann vielleicht dann sauer sein,
wenn man irgendwas kritisiert, aber ich habe tatsächlich auch da einige Kritikpunkte
zu bringen, aber ist eine andere Geschichte.
Aber zumindest ist der serbische Wikipedia einfach nicht vergleichbar mit den
Deutschen, das muss man schon sagen. Es sind Welten dazwischen.
Ja, also den Eindruck hatte ich auch, habe das dann schnell wieder abgebrochen,
weil ich dachte, das ist jetzt hier irgendwie so nicht der Punkt.
Eine sehr viel ausführlichere Timeline findet man natürlich auf deinem Masodan-Account,
wo du, glaube ich, primär im Wesentlichen berichtest.
Aber wir haben ja jetzt hier diesen Podcast und wollen mal ein bisschen chronologisch
anknüpfen an das, was wir zuletzt berichtet hatten.
Wir hatten Die Sendung veröffentlicht am 25.
April 25 und ja, dann steigen wir doch mal ein Ende April. Was ist denn passiert?
Ja, also ich versuche mal so ein bisschen immer so ein paar Punkte chronologisch aufzuzählen.
Es ist tatsächlich schwierig, weil es gibt im Endeffekt zwei Optionen,
wenn man Serbien oder den Verlauf sich betrachten möchte.
Zum einen chronologisch, zum anderen können die natürlich auch Themen rauspicken
und sagen, lass uns mal gucken in der einen Thematik, was ist da geschehen.
Aber zeitgleich ist es so, dass wenn ich die eine Thematik rauspicke,
ist die halt immer zusammenhängend mit der anderen Thematik.
Das heißt, die Dinge bedingen sich einfach.
Es ist einfach ein komplexer Verlauf, ein komplexes Thema.
Deswegen wird es immer nie die Lage komplett erfassen, alles was im Prinzip ich erzählen.
Aber jetzt ein bisschen so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, was Ende April tatsächlich
nochmal hinzugekommen ist, sind viele zahlreiche Schüler in Protestmärsche.
Das heißt, wir hatten in der letzten Folge darüber gesprochen,
wie eben über Protestmärsche Studentinnen mit Menschen in verschiedenen Dörfern
und abgelegenen Ortschaften ins Gespräch gekommen sind,
wo sie halt eben über Protestmärsche zu großen Demos gelaufen sind,
wo sie sich dann wieder mit anderen Menschen aus dem ganzen Land getroffen haben.
Das heißt, diese Protestmärsche haben verschiedene Funktionen erfüllt und jetzt
haben Schüler angefangen auch so die Protestmärsche durchzuführen und aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Natürlich wiederum anderer Zugang, andere Perspektive, auch ein Empowerment.
Das hat sich, glaube ich, auch rumgesprochen, dass er mit einem etwas macht,
weil du eben dann aktiv was handeln kannst, was tun kannst, Sichtbarkeit bekommst.
Also es gibt tatsächlich verschiedene Funktionen und Wirkungen von diesen Protestmärschen.
Diese Protestmärkte haben auf jeden Fall massiv, glaube ich,
noch mal in der Gesellschaft etwas ausgelöst, weil es gab Bilder,
wo einfach es geschüttet ohne Ende.
Du siehst einfach diese Kolonne von Schülern, die einfach unabhängig von diesem
Wetter, Unwetter, einfach Kilometer für Kilometer runterlaufen,
um zu so einem Protest zu gelangen. Und das hat natürlich echt viele, viele beeindruckt.
Dann hast du auch so eine.
Arbeitsgruppe, die ist im Vorschein getreten, die tatsächlich glaube ich Anfang
März sich gegründet hat.
Die nennt sich StudentInnen in jedem Dorf und ist eine Arbeitsgruppe von StudentInnen,
die einzelne Dörfer, abgelegene Kommunen immer wieder besuchen.
Ich glaube jedes Wochenende haben die so Termine gesetzt. In der Regel auch
mit der Idee, dass StudentInnen da hingehen, die selbst aus dem Dorf kommen.
Das heißt, du hast natürlich viel in Belgrad und anderen Städten,
aber ich glaube es sind hauptsächlich in Belgrad, da bin ich ganz sicher.
Hast du Studenten, die aus dem ganzen Land anreisen und da dann studieren und
dann für mehrere Jahre in Belgrad leben.
Und wenn die natürlich nach ihrem Heimatdorf zurückkehren für so eine Aktion,
haben die natürlich einen anderen Zugang zu Menschen, als jetzt jemand,
der von der Stadt irgendwie dahin fährt.
Deswegen haben die tatsächlich diese Aktion gestartet, um einfach mit Bürgern
ins Gespräch zu kommen, um wieder so einen Gegenpol zu setzen zu dem,
was medial verkündet wird.
Vor allem, man muss da auch sagen, in der letzten Folge darüber gesprochen,
Medien sind natürlich sehr, sehr stark in der Hand von dem Vucic-Regime und
dementsprechend, wenn du jetzt nicht in Belgrad bist und auch Zugang zu gewissen Kanälen hast,
bekommst du eigentlich nur das Staatsfernsehen mit oder die Kanäle mit,
die auf Staatsfrequenz gesendet werden und die sind sehr, sehr einseitig und
schreiben auch Dinge, die einfach verkürzt sind oder einfach gelogen, wenn man ehrlich ist.
Und da ist natürlich eben wichtig, auch so eine Gegenstimme zu haben und darum
ist das eine sehr, sehr wichtige Arbeit, die seit Monaten von denen geleistet wird.
Genau. Das heißt, die Kernprimären ihrer eigenen Heimatdörfer zurück und machen
dann dort Veranstaltungen oder Besuchen?
Die haben tatsächlich so einen Tisch, den sie aufbauen und da steht dran eben,
komm ins Gespräch mit Studentinnen und dann kommen Menschen einfach da vorbei.
Es sind irgendwie Dorfplätze oder irgendwie so eine Hauptstraße von so einem
Dorf und dann kommen die ins Gespräch.
Manchmal quatschen die mit fünf Leuten, manchmal mit 50 Leuten.
Das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Die haben auch teilweise auch Flyer, die sie mitgenommen haben,
wo sie einfach nochmal erklären, was die Anliegen der Studentinnen sind.
Wer die Studentinnen sind.
Auch um Desinfektion tatsächlich auch entgegenzuwirken, weil auch dementsprechend
aufgeklassen und sagt, was denn nicht richtig ist, was in der Regel über Medien kommuniziert wird.
Also das heißt, das ist jetzt tatsächlich eine sehr, sehr mühsame,
aber sehr wichtige Arbeit, die sie über viele Monate leisten.
Aber dieser Zugang, der kann auch stattfinden.
Wir hatten, glaube ich, letztes Mal darüber gesprochen, über so den Status,
den Studenten haben, der nicht ganz so zu vergleichen ist, wie wir das jetzt
hier kennen, wo ja oft so Studenten so als so Elite angesehen werden und so
ein bisschen ein anderer Teil der Bevölkerung ist.
Da Serbien noch sehr restsozialistisch geprägt ist an der Stelle,
ist Studieren eigentlich ein vollkommen normaler Vorgang, der,
sagen wir mal, sehr breit in der Bevölkerung stattfindet.
Witzigerweise, ich habe tatsächlich viele Podcasts zu der Thematik angehört,
ich glaube ich habe jetzt keine Daten und Zahlen gefunden die erfassen,
wie viele Menschen die das Abitur gemacht haben, studieren also um zu gucken, so dieses,
wie viele Akademiker studieren, so der klassische Gap, den man kennt ist aus
dem deutschsprachigen Raum,
aber den Gesprächen nach, den Informationen nach, würde ich tatsächlich sagen,
dass sehr, sehr viele also auch sehr, sehr breiten Teil der Gesellschaft eben
studieren können, noch studieren können und studieren können verbunden natürlich
trotzdem mit auch gewissen Hürden wiederum.
Das heißt, ganz so easy ist es nicht, aber du kannst das.
Und deswegen ist tatsächlich Durchmischung weitaus höher und größer als jetzt
im deutschen Raum zum Beispiel.
Ja, okay, das meinte ich auch. Also klar, ist immer noch ein Unterschied am
Ende. Muss man es natürlich auch leisten können.
Ja, wie ging es dann weiter?
Ja, es gab dann, Ende April habe ich hier aufgeschrieben gehabt,
war zum Beispiel noch die Geschichte, dass eben diese,
Blockade, weil in den letzten Folgen darüber gesprochen ist,
dass der öffentliche, rechtliche im Serbien, also das Fernsehen, TV, Radio,
besetzt wurde von Studentinnen.
Und das wurde tatsächlich dann aufgehoben Ende April. Das heißt die Blockade,
weil eben dann die Ausschreibung stattgefunden hat.
Und zwar gibt es dann so eine Kontrollinstanz, REM heißt die da,
und die reguliert eigentlich, wer auf welchen Frequenzen senden darf,
wer gegen welche ethische Regeln verstößt und so weiter.
Ich muss dazu sagen, Das ist tatsächlich da ausgeschrieben worden.
Der Prozess ist bis heute nicht abgeschlossen worden.
Das heißt, er hat bis heute nicht diese Instanz, was auch ein massives Problem darstellt.
Weil man kann sich ja vorstellen, es sind tatsächlich in den letzten Monaten
unfassbar viele Verstöße gemacht
worden auf verschiedenen TV-Sendungen und Kanälen, die da stattfinden.
Also wenn ich da jetzt darauf eingehen würde, was da zum Teil gesagt wird und
wie gesagt wurde, können wir vielleicht auch später machen an verschiedenen
Fällen, die noch kommen werden,
dann wird nochmal deutlich, wie sehr diese regulierende Instanz einfach hier
fehlt und natürlich dann auch dem Regime in die Hände spielt.
Aber warum hat denn die Besetzung geendet, wenn es immer noch keine Ausschreibung gibt?
Weil da die Ausschreibung erstmal verkündet wurde und es war tatsächlich die Forderung von denen.
Die haben gesagt, die blockieren, bis diese Ausschreibung der Prozess in Gang gesetzt wird.
Natürlich mit der Idee, jetzt wird der Prozess auch dementsprechend,
weil alle draufschauen, dann durchgeführt werden.
Aber wird weiterhin verschleppt sozusagen. Genau, wir haben es verschleppt.
Man muss dazu sagen, aber auch, das ist bei all den Protestformen,
die du hast, also auch mann-viel-Blockade, der physischen Blockaden der Universitäten,
der Fakultäten, ist halt immer so der Punkt, du kommst am gewissen Punkt an
so eine Stelle, wo du merkst oder dich einfach auch fragen musst,
wie hoch ist der Impact und wie hoch ist die Ressource, die du hier bereitstellen
musst für diesen Impact.
Und an manchen Stellen hat man das auch sehr kontrovers angefangen zu diskutieren.
Das heißt, inwiefern ist Impact noch da und ob man sich anders organisieren
kann mit einem höheren Impact und weniger Ressourcen investieren muss,
weil die Ressourcen schon unfassbar kräftezehrend sind.
Klar.
All right.
Und das war, glaube ich, so im Wesentlichen das, was dann noch im April passiert ist, richtig?
Genau, genau, genau. Und dann kam der Mai mit einigen Sachen,
die nochmal so, die man schon als Wende verstehen kann in der ganzen Entwicklung.
Also klar, es gibt so kleine Geschichten, die so parallel nebenher gelaufen
sind, wie zum Beispiel, dass die zum 1.
Mai, also Tag der Arbeit gab es eben dann zum ersten Mal, dass sich alle nationalen
großen Gewerkschaften zusammen aufgetreten sind auf Initiative von Studentinnen,
die über Monate hinweg im Hintergrund gearbeitet haben, die gesprochen haben.
Das Thema Gewerkschaften ist ein sehr komplexes Thema, auch sehr kritisch betrachtet,
auch in Serbien, weil die einfach tatsächlich systematisch unterwandert wurden über Jahrzehnte.
Und jetzt die Frage immer ist so, gehönt man neue Gewerkschaften oder versucht
man die bestehenden Systeme einfach dann wieder zu oberen über verschiedene Wahlen und so weiter.
Das heißt, es ist ein sehr komplexes Thema, aber auf jeden Fall etwas, wo man Hebel sieht.
Ich würde sagen, mittlerweile ist tatsächlich so die Entwicklung,
als wenn es aktuell auf heute switchen würde, wir gehen da wieder zurück,
dass man in vielen Bereichen eigentlich so die Strategie verfolgt,
über diesen gängigen Weg die Macht wieder an sich zu reißen und zu demokratisieren.
Das heißt also zum Beispiel eher die Strategie zu folgen, in Gewerkschaften
selbst bei Wahlen einzutreten, Leute zu mobilisieren und dann wieder Gewerkschaften
Gewerkschaften sein lassen.
Weil dieses neue Sachen gründen ist nicht so einfach aus verschiedenen Gründen,
weil letzten Endes musst du auch da wiederum einen Prozess durchlaufen,
auch der dann das legal macht und legitimiert,
was eigentlich eben, weil eben das System ist, wie es gerade da ist und werden
solche Sachen verhindert.
Das heißt, dem Regime fällt es leicht, solche Prozesse sinnvoll wären,
einfach zu verhindern oder nicht zustande kommen zu lassen, was für um dir es
erschwert, eben dann wirklich einen Impact zu entwickeln.
Deswegen ist es ein sehr, sehr komplexes Thema tatsächlich. Aber zumindest ist
da so nochmal aufgekommen.
Es gibt noch eine Arbeitsgruppe, die später sich nochmal aufgetreten ist als
gesellschaftliche Front.
Das heißt, aber da ist so entstanden die Idee von, lass uns doch mal ganz konkret
auf die Arbeiterinteressen schauen.
Und Arbeiter im Sinne von tatsächlich wirklich alle Bereiche,
von medizinischer Fachangestellte bis eben Landwirt.
Das heißt, dass wirklich von allen Perspektiven so geguckt wird,
was gibt es denn für einen Konsens?
Also so ein bisschen auch die Strategie zu folgen, die Studentinnen an sich
bei den ganzen Protesten ja auch schon immer gefahren haben,
zu schauen, was ist so Minimalkonsens?
Das ist etwas, wo wir uns alle dahinter stellen können.
Und da einfach Forderungen auszuarbeiten, die bestenfalls eben auch Gesetzestexte
münden, die man dann vielleicht nicht jetzt, aber zu einem anderen Zeitpunkt
dann eben umsetzen kann, um auch dann eben noch Rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen,
die einfach allen das Leben erleichtern.
Das ist so ein bisschen der Marsch durch die Institutionen, die wir so in Deutschland
in den 80er Jahren von linken Bewegungen ja gesehen haben, so als Reaktion auf
den deutschen Herbst, den RAF-Terror,
was ja dann zu den Grünen geführt hat.
Sicherlich teilweise auch erfolgreich. Aber ja, das ist natürlich klar,
dass man hier nicht gleich alles neu gründen will, weil da müsste man ja auch
erstmal Mitglieder gewinnen etc.
Leute hängen ja dann irgendwie auch aus irgendwelchen Gründen wahrscheinlich da dran.
Okay, interessant. Also würdest du sagen,
dass die Gewerkschaften zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt schon sich im Wesentlichen diesen
Protesten oder generell einem Wandel anschließen oder müssen die dazu erst noch getragen werden?
Nee, nee, das ist leider noch alles nicht wirklich gesund.
Das heißt, es scheint doch weitaus komplexer, als es auf den ersten Blick vielleicht
irgendwie Leute gedacht haben.
Das heißt, das Problem ist, dass
da halt so auch zum Beispiel so Vertrauensgeschichten mit drin hängen.
Du hast eine hohe Skepsis, also es ist tatsächlich auch so eine Problematik,
die an vielen Stellen auftaucht, auch wenn wir vielleicht später auf das Thema
Opposition zu sprechen kommen oder Parteien an sich oder andere Vereinigungen an sich,
wenn wir jetzt auch gleich kommen, wenn wir zu neuen Forderungen,
zu Kurswechsel kommen werden, dann stellt man fest, dass dieses Vertrauensverlust
in Institutionen, Vertrauensverlust in Organisationen, dass das tatsächlich
eben auch eine sehr, sehr große Hürde darstellt.
Weil auf der einen Seite brauchst du Verbündete und einen gewissen Impact zu erreichen.
Zeitgleich bist du natürlich ein gebranntes Kind, weil du einfach Erfahrungen
gemacht hast, wie einfach Leute dann, die dich im Stich gelassen haben oder
an manchen Stellen dann auch im Endeffekt dann Sachen unterwandert haben oder
geschwächt haben oder du im Endeffekt dann auf einem Messer gelaufen bist.
Und deswegen ist tatsächlich so dieses, diese auf der einen Seite gesunde Skepsis,
auf der anderen Seite ist so eine Hürde dann entstanden, die wiederum eben die
Solidarität und Bündnisse erschwert an manchen Stellen.
All right.
Und dann, genau, ja, dann kommen wir so ein bisschen, ich habe das angedeutet im letzten Podcast,
dass die Bürger in Versammlungen angefangen haben, sich zu etablieren und das
ist schon etwas, was jetzt bis heute, also da begonnen hat und bis heute sehr
stark anhält und das heißt, es gibt einmal so eine Rechtsform,
wo Bürger in Versammlungen tatsächlich auch eben gesetzlich verankert stattfinden können.
Das ist etwas, wo auch gewählt wird und so weiter. Das ist eine Sache,
die auch wiederum zum Beispiel jetzt vermehrt versucht wird,
eben von Zivilgesellschaft eben wieder, dass man es übernimmt.
Und das andere sind diese Bürgerinversammlungen in Bordewi. Das heißt,
es ist etwas, was eben noch keine Rechtsform hat.
Also im Rechtsformsinn von, dass du jetzt nicht irgendwelche Forderungen groß
stellen kannst, aber tatsächlich in der Vergangenheit Erfahrungen gemacht wurde,
dass tatsächlich die Forderungen gestellt haben, die auch anerkannt wurden von
der Kommune, von der Verwaltung und dementsprechend wohl auch ein Symbol dann waren,
dass sie anerkannt werden dann doch, obwohl jetzt vielleicht noch nicht verschriftlicht
irgendwo im System vorkommen.
Also zumindest nicht mit dem Impact, den sie eigentlich jetzt haben könnten.
Also es war, ich möchte mal so sagen, stell dir sowas vor wie Bürgervereine,
die du jetzt vielleicht aus irgendwie Städten kennst, in Kommunen, also in Stadtteilen.
Und Bürgervereine haben ja auch hier gewisse Rechte, die sie nutzen können.
Und so ähnlich wie Bürgervereine hast du ja auch wiederum eben was in Serbien
auch, Aber tatsächlich einen anderen Kontext, andere Geschichte,
aber auch auf dieser Ebene der kommunalen Verwaltung, wo auch den meisten BürgerInnen
in Stadtteilen, Kommunen einfach dann gefragt werden kannst,
gehört werden kannst und Ressourcen bekommst und so weiter.
Und parallel dazu haben die aber diese Bürgerversammlungen, ich nenne sie Bürgerversammlungen,
gestartet, die nicht das sind, aber wiederum sich anders organisieren.
Und die haben sie organisiert wie die Pläne, wie die Studentinnen.
Das heißt, das ist das. Und das ist tatsächlich sehr erfolgreich gewesen,
weil die tatsächlich dann über Messenger-Dienste auch dann teilweise woanders mitlesen.
Das heißt auch dann dementsprechend schnell informiert werden,
gemeinsam sich auch dann verbinden können und dann Sachen relativ schnell wuppen können.
Das heißt, das ist etwas, was bis heute sich sehr stark durchgesetzt hat.
Und diese Bürgerinversammlungen sind tatsächlich mittlerweile eine sehr tragende
Säule von den Protesten in Serbien.
Und damals tatsächlich, würde ich sagen, jetzt nach dem 15.
März und dieser ganzen Enttäuschung, die danach gefolgt ist,
ist das tatsächlich so, da hat es angefangen so zu wachsen und sich zu entwickeln.
Also 15. März diese Großdemo in Belgrad, wo auch da diese Schallwaffe eingesetzt wurde und so weiter.
Das heißt, diese Bürgerversammlungen sind so ein Phänomen, was sich jetzt quasi
über die Gemeinden im Land ausbreitet.
Dass Bürger einer Gemeinde, eines Dorfes, was auch immer, sagen,
wir bauen jetzt hier quasi so eine eigene...
Kommunale Verwaltung.
Eine eigene Verwaltung Richtung, richtig?
Ach, zumindest nicht Verwaltung, aber vielleicht Bürgerinvertretung.
Ja, so ein Rat, der einfach sagt, wir reden jetzt hier mit.
Es gibt nicht nur den Bürgermeister, sondern wir wollen jetzt sozusagen auch
aus dem Volk heraus hier irgendwas machen.
Aber wie reagieren denn dann quasi die offiziellen, diesen neu gegründeten Organisationen gegenüber?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich eben interessant. Ich habe in einer Stelle gab es mal,
ich habe das nicht aus den Augen verloren, an einer Stelle gab es eben,
habe ich nur erfahren, dass in Novi Sad zum Beispiel, diese Bürger,
also ich habe es mit Bürgerverein verglichen vorhin, dass diese,
die einfach so strukturell nicht verankert sind.
Dass die die Wahlen einfach nicht ausgeschrieben wurden.
Das heißt, diese Wahlen ausgesetzt, weil man Angst hatte in Novi Sad,
dass diese Wahlen, wenn man sich durchführen würde, dass die dementsprechend einfach dann.
Weil jetzt, wenn die aktuell geführt von Personen, die in der Partei sind von
Vucic und dementsprechend auch dann regimetreu werden die gehandhabt,
das heißt wie die Ressourcen ausgegeben werden und so weiter.
Das heißt alles ist in Parteihand noch und wenn jetzt diese Wahl da ausschreiben,
das auf dieser niedersten Ebene, auf der kommunalen niedersten Ebene,
dann würden die hundertprozentig diese Wahlen einfach verlieren und da würden
die ein Ding nach dem anderen einfach kippen und deswegen wurden zum Beispiel
Nobisat, wo sehr, sehr viele diese messenden Seidnitze heißen die,
diese Wahl wurden tatsächlich dann nicht ausgeschrieben.
Und jetzt kannst du dir vorstellen, deswegen meinte ich ja, ich habe das hier
wieder auf Fälle gesehen, wo dann diese Bürgerinvertretungen eben dann einfach
jetzt ihre Arbeit machen und sagen, wir sind Bürgerinvertretungen und an manchen
Stellen Forderungen gestellt haben und diese Forderungen von der Kommune umgesetzt wurden.
Was wiederum bedeutet, dass sie eigentlich dann in dieser, sobald ich das akzeptiere,
diese Forderung akzeptiere, akzeptiere ich dich wiederum als legitime Vertretung von BürgerInnen.
Und das war tatsächlich so an vielen Stellen, also deswegen,
man muss glaube ich von Kommune zu Kommune, von Stadt zu Stadt irgendwie durchgehen,
aber welche Rolle die haben, die sind tatsächlich unterschiedlich stark,
also wenn man jetzt auch guckt, es gibt verschiedene,
diese Bürgerversammlungen in verschiedenen Stadtteilen, die unterschiedlich
breit aufgestellt sind, die einen höheren Impact haben, geringen Impact haben,
je nach Stadtteil teilweise auch und je nach auch einer, also welche Personen
auch da drin so ein bisschen Admins sind.
Das ist interessant. Also die Kommunalwahlen selbst werden ausgesetzt,
um zu verhindern, dass man quasi abgewählt wird, aber dann bilden sich diese Bürgervereine,
die dann einfach so viel Power entwickeln, dadurch, dass sie sich einfach aufstellen und sagen,
an uns führt jetzt kein Weg dran vorbei,
dass quasi die Bürgermeister und die Räte oder was auch immer da die Struktur
ist quasi klein beigeben müssen und sagen müssen, naja, okay,
meinetwegen, Hauptsache ihr wählt mich nicht ab.
Ja, es ist tatsächlich, es ist insofern spannend, weil ich auch da wieder um
eine Zeit lang verfolgt habe, es ist schwierig, jedes Detail immer so fertig
zu Ende zu verfolgen, weil es sind tatsächlich sehr, sehr, sehr tief einschneidende
oder eingehende, komplexe Themen.
Ich versuche alles so ein bisschen mitzubekommen, was so passiert.
Aber ich habe schon auch mitbekommen, dass eben auch Diskussionen da waren,
die auch wiederum zu legitimieren.
Das heißt also wiederum auch da, die in die Satzung oder wo auch immer irgendeinem
Teil von Verfassung mit aufzunehmen, damit diese Organe, damit es auch beibehalten werden kann.
Zeitlich haben andere gesagt, aber wenn wir dann wiederum normale Wahlen hätten
auf diesen niedrigsten kommunalen Ebenen, dann bräuchte man die nicht,
weil wir können dann darüber diese Arbeit leisten.
Deswegen ist es immer so hin und her, was machst du, an welcher Stelle gehst
du wie vor, was ist strategisch jetzt notwendig. Also dieses kurzfristig,
mittelfristig, langfristig planen und umsetzen ist tatsächlich eine komplexe Geschichte.
Ich weiß, es ist schwierig zu beantworten, aber nur mal so ein Gefühl zu bekommen,
was würdest du meinen, in wie vielen Gemeinden haben sich solche Bürgervereine gegründet?
Ist das jetzt so hier und da mal oder sind das schon richtig viele oder findet
das nur in bestimmten Teilen des Landes statt und andere haben davon noch nie gehört?
Also das ist zum Beispiel eine Sache, die ich so gar nicht fassen kann.
Ich habe mich am Anfang natürlich stark damit beschäftigt mit Belgrad,
weil ich eben aus Belgrad komme und da ich in so einem Ding drin war oder bin
und auch verfolge, was da so gemacht wird.
Habe dann erst so die Wochen später mitbekommen, in anderen Städten gibt es das auch.
Und einfach über Accounts, die aufgepoppt sind. Das heißt, du hast einfach dann
das Board so und so und da steht dann immer diese Bürgerinversammlung und dann
eben die Stadt dahinter oder die Kommune dahinter.
Und da habe ich schon wirklich von großen bis kleinen Städten bis Dörfern alles
gesehen. Das heißt, ich kann es gar nicht fassen, aber ich weiß tatsächlich,
dass es in vielen, vielen, also landesweit, die einfach gibt und die tatsächlich
sehr, sehr unterschiedlich sehr stark aktiv sind.
Also zum Beispiel zum einen haben die jetzt auch so einen Verein daraus gegründet,
in Ujiz war das, glaube ich, und da versuchen die jetzt nochmal noch massiver
aufzutreten, noch mehr auch politisch mit einzugreifen, auch politische Forderungen zu stellen.
Also jetzt tatsächlich, das ist tatsächlich sehr, sehr unterschiedlich, je nach,
ich glaube, dass der Impact sehr, sehr unterschiedlich ist, weil ich glaube
gerade dieser Impact in so kleineren Dörfern, Kommunen oder Städten natürlich
eine andere Nummer ist als in so einer Großstadt, wo einfach dann eben halt
von vielen Stadtbezirken einfach so eine Bürgerinversammlung darstellst.
Ja, und was macht eigentlich Alexander Vucic, der amtierende Präsident,
der ja für nichts zuständig ist, wie wir in der letzten Folge gelernt haben?
Ja, der ist für nichts zuständig, aber natürlich ein sehr, sehr tolles Flugzeug,
was sich gekauft hat. Und im Mai ist er nach den USA gereist.
Und mit der Idee damals, da wollte er, glaube ich, einfach im Endeffekt ein
Foto generieren, er und Trump, um wiederum seiner Wählerinschaft oder seinen
Leuten, wie auch immer das ist,
eben zu transportieren, zu kommunizieren, schau, ich bin relevant,
ich bin hier, treff mit den wichtigsten Menschen dieser Welt,
weil tatsächlich die Wochen darauf war auch geplant eben die Moskau-Reise.
Das heißt, er wollte einfach so zeigen, hier mit Trump, da mit Putin und so weiter.
Das war, glaube ich, so sein Plan, weil er in seiner Erzählung eben,
wie gesagt, der geopolitisch wichtigste Mensch ist und alle Fäden in der Hand hält.
Und eigentlich dann, ich glaube, in irgendeiner Geschichte hat er mal so erzählt,
dass ich glaube, er am liebsten nach Belgrad einladen würde,
seinem Szenario nach und dann Trump und Putin und alle anderen wichtigen Akteure,
globalen Akteure zusammenkommen und er dann moderierend die Welt rettet.
Die neue Schweiz. Das ist, glaube ich.
Sein Szenario gewesen. Ja, genau. Es ist völlig irre, aber ich weiß auch nicht.
Und ist natürlich gescheitert, weil er hat eine ziemlich hohe Summe gezahlt,
was irgendwie rauskam, um überhaupt so einen Termin zu bekommen,
weil da muss man scheinbar irgendwie so bezahlen, um bei Trump vorsprechen zu können,
und hat dann aber kam nicht durch, das heißt der hat da einen Abfuhr kassiert, hat man da rausgefunden,
und hat dann auf einmal komischerweise eine Krankheit entwickelt und musste
dann ganz schnell nach Belgrad gebracht werden ins Militärkrankenhaus,
weil er eben so stark erkrankt ist und da haben sich alle Sorgen gemacht und
den Präsidenten, aber zum Glück, zum Glück hat er es überlebt und es geht ihm gut.
Hatte nichts damit zu tun, dass er es einfach ablenken wollte von der Schmach,
dass er eben da nicht beim Trump aufschlagen konnte.
Plus dann die Reise nach Moskau ist auch wiederum echt nach hinten losgegangen.
Das heißt also all diese Idee, die er hatte, ich kann im Endeffekt als Geopolitiker,
das ein bisschen auch das, was jetzt bei meinem Land passiert, zu überdecken.
Im Endeffekt ging es voll nach hinten los, weil zeitgleich auch noch die ganzen
Aktionen waren schon von den Studentinnen.
Das heißt, diese Geschichte mit dem Fahrradfahren nach Strasbourg.
Und dann gab es ja nochmal danach das Joggen, was auch ein bisschen in Mai hineinging,
da gab es einen Staffellauf von Läufern, die auch gestartet sind nach Brüssel
nochmal, das heißt, da gab es eine Überschrift, lautet das eben,
während er irgendwie untergeht in den USA, in Thron, in die Studentinnen in Europa.
Und das fand ich ganz passend, den Vergleich.
Und seitgleich hat er Mai, unabhängig von dieser Entwicklung mit Vucic,
hat tatsächlich nochmal einen großen Kurswechsel in der Entwicklung in Serbien
hervorgebracht und zwar haben Studentinnen Anfang Mai verkündet,
dass sie Neuwahlen fordern.
Und jetzt ändert sich die Sachklage grundlegend, weil auf einmal eine Person
zuständig ist, die bisher nicht zuständig war.
Und zwar Alexander Vucic. Das heißt, er ist tatsächlich die Person,
die für genau diesen Punkt zuständig ist und diese Neuwahlen eben ausschreiben kann.
Und du kannst dir natürlich vorstellen, wie das bei ihm ankam und wie er es
genossen hat, auf einmal zuständig zu sein und seitdem eben die Karte spielt,
das eben natürlich nicht zu machen.
Das heißt, keine Neuwahlen durchzuführen, obwohl einfach die letzten Jahre einfach
geglänzt haben vor unzähligen Neuwahlen.
Und das heißt, ich glaube, die regulären Wahlen waren, das letzte Mal reguläre Wahlen waren.
Das heißt, er hat immer wieder diese Masche gehabt von, ich möchte zeigen,
dass ich legitim gewählt bin, indem er einfach eine Krise mit Wahlen gelöst
hat und gezeigt hat, schau, ich bin doch hier gewählt worden von einem Großteil
der Bevölkerung und dementsprechend Krise gelöst.
Das kann er jetzt nicht mehr machen, weil er auch gesehen hat,
das wird jetzt nicht funktionieren und zumindest einfach auch Angst hat.
Und ich gehe davon aus, dass er definitiv Ratings hat und Zahlen hat,
die ihm aufschlussreich zeigen, wie die Lage gerade im Land ist.
Und es gibt tatsächlich auch so Ratingzahlen, die immer wieder eigentlich veröffentlicht
wurden, die seit Monaten nicht mehr veröffentlicht werden, auch aus seinen Instituten
auch, aus regimenahen Instituten, wo man überhaupt ablesen kann,
wie das Rating aktuell ist.
Aber auf jeden Fall ist diese Forderung von Studentinnen tatsächlich so ein
Kurswechsel entstanden.
Und natürlich auch mit der Idee, wenn jetzt Wahlen kommen, wie soll es denn
ablaufen mit Wahlen? Und dann haben eben Studentinnen gesagt,
dass es eine Studentenliste geben wird.
Und dann war die Studentenliste jetzt etwas, was eben relativ lange diesen Mai dominiert hat.
Wie wird sie aufgestellt? wer soll da drauf kommen, wie sollen überhaupt faire
Wahlen gelingen und so weiter und so weiter.
Also ich habe mal kurz geguckt, also Präsidentschaftswahlen,
also Wucic gewählt wurde, jetzt war 2022,
das heißt, wenn das ein Fünfjahreszyklus ist, wäre es sozusagen dann erst im April 27 wieder soweit.
Die Parlamentswahlen wiederum haben...
Und ja, da gab es so verschiedene neue Wahlen, die letzte im Dezember 23.
Tja, die wurden aber auch von Vucic schon vorgezogen.
Also das war quasi, ist also durchaus möglich, dass aufgrund von Protesten sowas stattfindet.
Das ist tatsächlich auch eine Sache, die gefordert wird, also Wahlen,
nicht nur Präsidentschaftswahlen, sondern natürlich auch Parlamentswahlen,
sondern wirklich auf allen Ebenen, also auch auf kommunaler Ebene, auf städtischer Ebene.
Das heißt, das ist eine Forderung, auf allen Ebenen sollen neue Wahlen ausgeschrieben werden, stattfinden.
Es ist tatsächlich so, dass die Liste so erstellt werden soll,
dass einfach Leute, Personen auf der Liste stehen werden, die nicht Amtsträger
sind von irgendeinen Parteien.
Dass auf jeden Fall niemand aus irgendeiner Partei, die aktuell in der Regierung
ist, im Prinzip da draufstehen wird.
Und dass im Endeffekt hauptsächlich Menschen draufstehen werden,
Personen draufstehen werden, die sich einfach in den letzten Monaten hervorgetan
haben mit einer authentischen Unterstützung dieser ganzen Proteste und mit einer
gewissen Fachexpertise.
Das heißt aber tatsächlich eben auch divers, also angefangen von Professorinnen
bis zu Landwirtinnen, bis zu Aktivistinnen, soll da verschiedenste Personen
draufstehen und soll auch so aufgeteilt sein, die Liste, dass auch die verschiedenen
Universitätsstädte, die im Endeffekt im ganzen Land verteilt sind,
dass die wiederum auch unterschiedliche Kontingente bekommen von einer Person,
die auf der Liste stehen sollen.
Das heißt, da wird auch so ein Verfahren dann vorgestellt, wie es ablaufen soll.
Aber im Endeffekt, das ist so die Liste.
Und jetzt ist aktuell wieder das Thema, wann wird sie kommuniziert,
wann wird sie kommuniziert. Und die muss man jetzt einfach mal veröffentlichen.
Die haben damals im Mai gesagt, und da haben sie bis jetzt dann festgehalten,
die werden die Liste erst dann veröffentlichen, wenn Neuwahlen ausgeschrieben wurden.
Und zwar aus einem relativ einfachen Grund.
Wenn du die Liste veröffentlichst, dann wird im Endeffekt medial das passieren,
was immer passiert. Einfach, dass das Vorgehen ist von diesem Regime.
Einzelpersonen würden einfach rausgepickt werden und so medial angegangen werden,
und unter Druck gesetzt werden, dass einfach, glaube ich, das zum einen sie
massiv belasten würde, ihr Leben, das Leben ihrer Familie, ihres Umfeldes,
als auch vielleicht auch die Wirkung dieser Liste.
Und das ist glaube ich der Hauptgrund, wieso sie gesagt haben,
diese Liste werden sie in dem Fall nicht veröffentlichen und die Argumentieren
relativ klug finde ich, die sagen auch, ja gut,
eure Liste ist ja auch nicht veröffentlicht, wenn er antritt das heißt,
schreibt doch einfach Wahlen aus und dann wenn du da eine Liste veröffentlicht,
veröffentlicht unsere Liste und dann können wir in die Wahlen gehen.
Alright, also die Forderung steht im Raum und Vucic muss sich in gewisser Hinsicht
dazu verhalten, aber hat es gerade nicht besonders eilig, sich dazu zu verhalten.
Er hat tatsächlich immer wieder verschiedene Aussagen getroffen.
Ich habe auch mal eine Aussage gehabt, wo es irgendwie so in die Richtung gegen
das Ende Juni schon Wahlen stattfinden sollen.
Es wird jetzt schneller kommen, als er denkt, aber das Ding ist,
er haut ja, das ist dieses,
ich habe es mal vor kurzem gepostet, er macht da dieses.
Flood the Zone with Shit permanent, das heißt, er haut ja Sachen raus,
wo dann Leute, Analysten da sitzen und überlegen, wie er es gemeint haben könnte
und da wird Ressource investiert bei manchen Leuten und was tatsächlich die
Studentin-Zivilgeschaft nicht macht,
die fallen da nicht drauf rein, das heißt, sie sagen, alles klar,
der erzählt eh so viel Müll und der lügt einfach die ganze Zeit auch.
Das heißt, damit am besten gar nicht beschäftigen, sondern lass uns unsere Arbeit machen.
Das heißt, die haben Studentinnen, Zivilgesellschaft angefangen,
eben zum Beispiel Menschen zu informieren und zu sagen, hey,
prüf mal, ob du auf dem Wählerverzeichnis bist. Falls nicht,
kümmere dich darum, dass du drinstehst.
Oder lass dich fortbilden für Wahlen. Das heißt, entweder als als,
ja, dass du bei den Wahlen, beim Wahlvorgang selbst mithilfst,
als Helfer oder eben als Kontrolleur.
Das heißt, da kann man sich ausbilden lassen.
Das heißt, das ist einfach alles, was jetzt dann irgendwann kommen wird,
dass man darauf vorbereitet ist und möglichst an all den Baustellen, die da sind,
einfach auch schon Lösungen hat oder versucht, dem entgegenzuwirken,
um einigermaßen, also im Rahmen dessen, was möglich ist, faire Wahlen zu bekommen.
Also allen ist klar, dass du trotzdem mit x-tausend Stimmen mehr haben musst
und alles, also so viel, du musst so eine krasse Mehrheit im Prinzip erreichen
bei den Wahlen, dass du es nicht mehr verleugnen kannst, dass du auch nicht mehr eben faken kannst.
Und das ist schon allen klar, dass auch diese Wahl selbst schon auch ein Risiko
darstellt, aber letzten Endes, das ist auch so die Erkenntnis der Studenten
gewesen, wieso sie gesagt haben, das haben wollen, führt halt keinen Weg dran vorbei, wenn du,
einen friedvollen Wechsel erreichen möchtest. Das heißt, ein zentraler Wert
dieser ganzen Proteste war immer,
dass sie eben jede Form von Gewalt ablehnen und im Endeffekt einen Wechsel haben
wollen des Regimes oder erreichen wollen ohne Einsatz von Gewalt.
Und das ist tatsächlich so der einzige Weg, den es einfach gibt,
zu sagen, du brauchst einfach Wahl.
Ja, aber mit der Friedhaftigkeit ist es dann nicht so gut gelaufen in der Folge,
sondern es ist eigentlich vermehrt zu Auseinandersetzungen gekommen,
wenn ich das richtig sehe, oder?
Ja, es ist tatsächlich so gewesen, dass es gab neben den Wahlen,
als es ausgeschrieben hat, gab es Anfang Juni zwei Kommunalwahlen,
also in zwei Orten eine Kommunalwahl.
In Kosieric und in Saitschar.
Das eine ist ein sehr kleiner Ort von 10.000 Einwohnern ungefähr und das andere
um die 50.000 Einwohnern.
Und es waren die ersten Wahlen, die so stattgefunden haben nach diesen ganzen Protesten hier.
Und da haben natürlich alle so drauf geblickt,
Was gelingt uns da? Gelingt uns da was? Und deswegen gab es tatsächlich dann
zum einen sehr großen Fokus darauf.
Und man hat da schon gemerkt, dass der Druck massiv wurde.
Das heißt, diese kleinen Orte wurden überspült mit Leuten aus Belgrad und anderen
Städten, die einfach Leute eingeschüchtert haben oder Leute bestochen haben.
Das heißt, du hast schon so gemerkt, dass diese Gewalt in verschiedensten Formen
einfach dann sich auf der Straße gezeigt hat und diese Dörfer oder Städte da
okkupiert wurden über einen langen Zeitraum und tatsächlich auch da sehr unschöne
Szenen auch dann waren, auch bei der Wahl selbst dann.
Und zeitgleich mit dieser Kommunalwahl gab es auch so eine Entwicklung,
dass man gesagt hat, man macht jetzt weg von diesem,
du hast einen großen Protest, sondern hin zu, wir machen viele Proteste an vielen
Orten und irgendwann, wir machen zeitgleich an vielen Orten Proteste.
Das heißt, es ist, weil es ist einfach natürlich jetzt ressourcentechnisch betrachtet,
wenn du natürlich alle von A nach B karren musst, kriegst du einfach Ressource.
Und so zu sagen zeitgleich, hey, lass uns einen Termin ausmachen,
jetzt gehen wir alle auf die Straße an dem Termin, ist für dich einfach deutlich leichter.
Plus, du gehst in deinem Ort, in deiner Stadt, da, wo du Menschen kennst,
gehst du gemeinsam auf die Straße. Das ist eine andere Wirkung auch nochmal.
Und das war auch nochmal so ein Strategiewechsel, der stattgefunden hat an der Stelle.
Und die Kommunalwahlen sind tatsächlich so verlaufen, dass man sagen kann,
die haben schon massive Einbrüche gehabt bei den Zahlen, das heißt bei dem Zuspruch.
Und der hat tatsächlich, glaube ich, alle Ressourcen, die es gab, medial
als auch sonstige staatliche ressourcen dass menschen ja gar nicht
sein dürften hingegangen sind und also alles an ressourcen was er hatte in seinem
ganzen regime hat er investiert in zwei kleinen orte und hat es dann gerade
so geschafft eine mehrheit zu bekommen und dazu gewinnen anführungszeichen wobei
auch da die wahlbeobachter in die unabhängige vor ort waren gesagt haben das waren keine.
Regulären Wahlen. Das heißt, da wurden auch dann eben Wahlzettel,
dann auf einmal sind sie verschwunden.
Das heißt, man hat dann x Belege und Nachweise gehabt, um klar zu sagen,
das war nicht reguläre Wahlen.
Und wenn ich ehrlich bin, bei einem Ort ist zum Beispiel es heute noch,
glaube ich, ich habe es jetzt nicht mehr so, ich habe es so ein bisschen nebenher
verfolgt, ist tatsächlich gerade wieder die Frage, ob es neue Wahlen geben muss,
weil auch die, also dieser Prozess ist immer nicht sehr abgeschlossen.
Dann gab es auch Klagen, die dann teilweise angenommen wurden.
Also es ist ein sehr komplexer Prozess gewesen. Letzten Endes,
was man mitnehmen kann, ist, diese Riesenmaschine, Maschinerie von dem Regime
hat nicht ausgereicht, um wirklich die klare Siege davon zu tragen in sehr kleinen Orten.
Und da war natürlich danach auch allen klar, wenn das an zwei Orten stattfindet,
während dann landesweit Wahlen, das kannst du nicht landesweit abläufen.
Das heißt, du hast nicht die Polizeikräfte, die Schläger-Truppen,
die Kohle, um das überall zeitgleich abzuliefern.
Und die Diabliebotschaft kam schon an, beim Regime.
Und dementsprechend ist auch diese Geschichte, was ich vorhin gesagt habe,
dass diese Wahlen auf dieser niedrigsten kommunalen Ebene nicht ausgeschrieben werden, war danach.
Das heißt, das war auch so eine Erkenntnis aus diesen Wahlen,
wieso man gesagt hat, da will ich es jetzt gar nicht haben, weil letzten Endes
laufen Gefahr, dass man einfach da scheitern und von Ebene zu Ebene einfach
dann eben die Personen verlieren an den führenden Positionen.
Also, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, hat die SNS, was ja jetzt die Partei von
Vucic ist, trotzdem noch in diesen Kommunalwahlen gewonnen auf dem Papier.
Aber Verluste, also das heißt, das ist schon noch,
Also was waren das jetzt für Regionen? Das waren ja so zwei Orte,
wenn ich das richtig sehe, die eher so im ländlichen Raum waren.
Ja, genau. Es folgen jetzt auch Kommunalwahlen tatsächlich im Herbst.
Da bin ich gespannt, wiefern die eine Rolle spielen werden.
Aber letzten Endes war es so diese Sondergeschichte einfach oder diese Sonderrolle
haben sie bekommen, weil es eben diese ersten so Wahlen waren,
die so nachgekommen sind. und man muss dazu sagen, dieses Gewinnen,
es war nicht wirklich Gewinnen.
Also die haben tatsächlich, es war ein bisschen schräg der Ablauf,
auch dieser Prozedur, wer dann diese Wahl gewinnt oder wer es verkündet,
weil die Opposition eigentlich tatsächlich gesagt hat, wir haben gewonnen und
dann später wurde es dann korrigiert,
und das ist diese Erstauszählung und Zweitauszählung und bei der Zweitauszählung
sind dann zum Beispiel einfach Stimmen dann, was man von Kartons weggekommen
und so Geschichten, also völlig schräge Kiste, weil nach der Erstauszählung
haben die gesagt, haben wir ganz klar gewonnen.
Uns war es natürlich auch so, dass sie verschiedene Systeme gefahren haben.
Ich glaube, in Kosjeric war es so, dass die eine Einheitsliste hatten.
Das heißt, nur eine Liste gegen die SNS-Partei und in Seitschal war es,
glaube ich, verschiedene Listen, die gegen die gekandidiert haben.
Also es gab dann auch wieder diesen Vergleich, auch zu gucken,
welche Liste, welche Methode funktioniert besser, weil auch das tatsächlich auf dieser,
Landesebene ausgeskutiert wird, ob es in dem Fall nur eine Liste geben soll
gegen das Regime oder ob sie im Endeffekt auch in der Opposition eine Listenprinzip
machen werden, auch sehr heiß umstritten, aber da war es das erste Mal so mit
ein bisschen Erfahrungswerte sammeln, was hat sich wo wie durchgesetzt.
Und was ist die Erkenntnis, welche Methode besser ist?
Also letzten Endes, ich glaube, das muss man auf kommunaler Ebene unterscheiden,
mit Landesebene, weil bei Kossierlich diese Geschichte, dass es eben sehr eindeutig
ist und klar ist, eine Liste war es eben klarer für die Leute, für wen sie stimmen.
Bei den anderen war es so, dass zum Beispiel so eine Nebenliste,
da gab es dann so eine Aufruhr vor der Wahl, wo dann gesagt wurde,
das ist eigentlich eine unterwanderte Liste, die sind eigentlich die Leute drin.
Und da merkst du natürlich, sobald du halt einfach eine Unklarheit drin hast,
wird es wiederum schwerer, irgendwie Leute zu... Also deswegen,
ich hätte jetzt gesagt, meine Erkenntnis, persönliche Erkenntnis,
aber da gibt es sicher Politologen, die sich besser auskennen,
ich hätte jetzt gesagt, mach eine Liste.
Und dann ist allen klar, das ist die Liste und fertig. Aber ich glaube,
das ist tatsächlich ja, utopisch. Ich glaube, das wird jetzt auf der Landesebene nicht gelingen.
Das heißt, da rechnen wir auf jeden Fall mit verschiedenen Listen und da muss
man immer auch gucken, was dann dabei rauskommt.
Okay, aber immerhin kommt da Bewegung ins Spiel.
Genau, da kommt Bewegung ins Spiel und es ist tatsächlich auch so der Punkt,
wo man sagen kann, da kam aber auch Gewalt mit dem Spiel, also ich würde sagen,
diese Repression oder repressive Politik war da sehr, sehr stark zu spüren,
vor allem für die Menschen einfach vor Ort.
Also die haben auch gesagt, die sind froh, wenn die Wahl vorbei ist,
weil die einfach echt okkupiert waren von irgendwelchen Leuten,
die sie nicht kennen. die kleinen Orte, da kennt sich jeder jeden.
Das war auch nochmal so eine völlig schräge Nummer.
Und dann gab es eben diesen großen Protest, auch wiederum so einen Wendepunkt
in den ganzen Entwicklungen am 28. Juni zum Beat of Done.
Das heißt, das war auch eine sehr, sehr große Demo, die so groß hätte werden sollen wie am 15. März.
Die Dimension hat es nicht erreicht, aber war trotzdem sehr,
sehr groß. Also waren auch wieder über 100.000 Menschen auf jeden Fall auf den Straßen.
Jetzt überall oder in Belgrad?
In Belgrad.
Ja, in Belgrad. Und da haben alle eingeladen, dass sie nach Belgrad kommen sollen.
Und da war es wieder die gleiche Geschichte wie am 15. März.
Also auf komischer Weise gab es einen Terroranschlag, wo oder einen Ankündigungs-Terroranschlag
auf die Bahn und fuhr die Bahn nicht. Das heißt, man konnte nicht in die Stadt reinfahren.
Die Busse fuhren auf einmal nicht mehr. Also das heißt, es wurde wieder so wie
am 15. März, die gleiche Wiederholung.
Das heißt, alles, was dir irgendwie hilft, in die Stadt zu kommen, wurde ausgesetzt.
Und du konntest da nicht kommen, aus verschiedenen Gründen, in die Stadt reinkommen,
hat die Leute nicht abgehalten, da hinzugehen.
Das heißt, es war wiederum sehr, sehr massiv, sehr, sehr großer Aufmarsch.
Dazu muss man sagen, man kann tatsächlich dazu gute Berichte auch im deutschsprachigen
Raum lesen, die sich kritisch damit auseinandersetzen, wer gesprochen hat bei der Demo.
Das heißt, es kam tatsächlich sehr, sehr stark, rechte Stimmen auch dazu Wort,
was wiederum eben dann auch bei einigen, also landesintern kontroversiert wird,
auch international wahrgenommen wurde, dass man so eben die Frage gestellt hat,
sind jetzt die städtischen Proteste unterwandert von den Rechten.
Das ist so der O-Ton gewesen, zusammen ganz stark verkürzt, der medial diskutiert wurde.
Und im Endeffekt war es dann so, dass am Ende dieser Demo haben die,
weil alle gesagt haben, okay, jetzt muss irgendwas folgen, jetzt muss was passieren.
Und dann gab es grünes Licht. Das heißt, sie haben grünes Licht eingeblendet
und erklärt, jetzt hat die V-Gesellschaft von Studenten ein grünes Licht bekommen,
das zu tun, was notwendig ist.
Und ich saß dann auch und dachte, okay.
Wer hat grünes Licht von wem, das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Die Studenten haben am Ende der Demo im Endeffekt so eine Rede gehalten und
haben gesagt, ab jetzt geben wir euch grünes Licht, das heißt der Zivilgesellschaft
grünes Licht, um das zu tun, was notwendig ist, um dahin zu kommen,
wohin wir kommen wollen.
Das war so die Kommunikation. Und jetzt ist aber nicht so richtig klar gewesen,
mir war nicht klar, was heißt das jetzt?
Alle standen dann da und ich habe tatsächlich Diskussionen auch in meinem Chat
gelesen von meiner Bürgerversammlung, wo die auch gedacht haben,
nächsten Tag gesagt haben, ich wusste jetzt nicht, was die wollen und was jetzt genau passieren soll.
Und da war es dann letztendlich so, dass dann tatsächlich da die Polizeikräfte
angefangen, also diesen gewaltsamen Gegenbürger in den Vorgang haben, die haben aufgelöst.
Da gab es natürlich einige Übergriffe. Und da war, glaube ich,
nochmal auch so eine starke Enttäuschung, glaube ich, nochmal da.
Auf vielen Seiten, weil ich glaube, auf der einen studentischen Seite war,
glaube ich, so eine Idee davon, ich weiß nicht, was die vorgestellt haben,
wahrscheinlich sehr unterschiedliche Szenarien, aber nach dem Motto,
wir gehen jetzt hier nicht weg, bevor jetzt die Regierung einfach weg ist.
Irgendwie so vielleicht. Und jetzt, welche Rolle Gewalt spielt,
ich glaube, da war die Vorstellung so unterschiedlich.
Auf jeden Fall haben da Leute, es gibt diese Provokateure, die vom Regime auch
eingesetzt werden, die würde ich jetzt an der Stelle erkennen,
vielleicht ist es nicht so, man kann es dann auch nicht so richtig belegen,
aber die sah jetzt für mich nicht so studentisch aus, sondern eher so als diese
klassischen Schläger-Trupp-Menschen von Vucic.
Die wieder auf die Polizei los sind. Und dann ist die Polizei drauf.
Und dann hat er angefangen, ihm dann zu vermöbeln. Und da gab es tatsächlich die ersten Festnahmen.
Und dann fing eigentlich so die erste, wenn wir mal sagen, die erste Eskalation
der Gewalt an, die dann in den nächsten Monaten massiv verstärkt wurde,
an verschiedenen Stellen, zu verschiedenen Punkten.
Aber ich würde sagen, es war so der erste Punkt, wo wirklich dann Gewalt von
Seiten der Polizei einfach massiv eingesetzt wurde gegen die Zivilbevölkerung.
Und der Punkt ist dann, Es ist nicht nur so ein Wechsel gewesen von diesem grünen
Licht und was soll da passieren, sondern letzten Endes wurde dann am nächsten
Tag klar, es geht darum, zivilen Ungehorsam zu leisten.
Und der zivile Ungehorsam, der begann tatsächlich dann, das haben die Ersten,
die es verstanden haben, waren in Semmun, in einem Stadtteil in Belgrad,
die sowieso bekannt sind für den Widerstand von Beginn an.
Also das Gymnasium mit denen geht ab von Beginn an, die Bevölkerung geht ab von Beginn an.
Das sind sehr, sehr, sehr eigene Personen, ein eigenes Viertel auch,
muss man sagen. Das ist auch tatsächlich architektonisch untypisch.
Und die wollen auch nicht als Belgier bezeichnet werden. Die nennen sich Simonsi.
Das heißt, die haben sich, ich habe da einen Kumpel gehabt, oder einen Kumpel.
Eigene Geschichte auf jeden Fall. Und die haben tatsächlich Folgendes gemacht.
Die haben angefangen eben Container irgendwie aufzustellen, Barrikaden aufzubauen
und haben Leute genau aus ihnen nachgemacht. Das heißt, angefangen,
Kontinenten aufzustellen, Barrikaden aufzubauen, Straßen zu blockieren und sie
wegen unseren Ungehorsam zu leisten.
Und dann hat sich da in den nächsten Wochen einfach verschiedene Szenen entwickelt.
Das heißt, angefangen von Straßenblockaden bis über die Straßenblockaden wurden
dann mit Polizeikräften, massiver Polizeipräsenz aufgelöst.
Und dann haben die Bürgern gesagt, pass auf, wir gehen jetzt nicht in Konflikte
rein, weil noch einmal, wir sind ja friedvoll, also müssen wir andere Strategien
entwickeln, haben die angefangen so Sachen zu machen wie,
sehr oft über einen Zebrastreifen zu laufen, um so eine Straße zu blockieren.
Und dann haben sie angefangen mobile Blockaden zu machen, das heißt Container
hinzuschieben, da kam Polizei, haben die weggeschoben und währenddessen sind
die aber weitergezogen, woanders haben da Container hingeschoben.
Und dann sind die Polizisten denen hinterhergerannt und haben immer so einen
Blokal nach dem anderen aufgelöst und da sind Memes entstanden,
kannst du dir ja vorstellen.
Und das war natürlich, und das war alles, muss man sagen, bei einer massiven
Hitzest, es waren Temperaturen bei 40 Grad und drüber und die Polizeikräfte
natürlich in voller Monitor mit teilweise Masken, es hat auch angefangen,
dass die Leute angefangen, Masken zu tragen, das war auch eine Strecke in der Kiste,
das heißt, zuvor habe ich es eigentlich so nicht gesehen und dann haben die
Leute angefangen, Masken zu tragen, dass du nur die Augen siehst und so aus
verschiedenen Gründen, Da gibt es auch tatsächlich sehr viele verschiedene Thesen,
unter anderem, dass zum Beispiel Leute angesetzt, die gar keine Polizisten sind.
Es gibt tatsächlich an verschiedenen Stellen Indikatoren dafür,
die darauf hinweisen, dass es durchaus sein könnte, dass in dem Fall auch Polizeikräfte
dabei waren, die keine Polizeikräfte waren.
Und dann gab es tatsächlich so diese zivilen Ungehorsam-Geschichten,
teilweise sehr unterhaltsam.
Und dann gab es im Süden Serbiens Brände,
Waldbrände, die wiederum diesen Schwung an neuen Bewegungen,
die entstanden ist mit zivilen Ungehorsam,
würde ich sagen, so gebremst haben, weil diese Brände einfach viele Menschenleben
bedroht haben und da wiederum aufgezeigt haben, wie Korruption tötet.
Das heißt, da kam Feuerwehr, also erst in Feuerwehr wurde gerufen, die kam nicht.
Irgendwann kamen irgendwie Fahrzeuge und dann waren die Fahrzeuge defekt und
konnten eigentlich gar nichts löschen.
Das heißt, du hast einfach gemerkt, dass die Infrastruktur, die da sein müsste, die war nicht da.
Und haben die dann Zivilgesellschaft, also wieder diese Bürgerversammlungen
und Studentinnen haben angefangen, Leute zu organisieren, die eben dann Material
und Expertise gesammelt haben und dann runtergefahren sind und vor Ort geholfen haben.
Das heißt im Endeffekt die Arbeit geleistet, die eigentlich der Staat leisten müsste.
Das greift ja im Prinzip auch wieder das ursprünglich auslösende Thema,
dieses eingestürzte Vordach, was offensichtlich durch Korruption nicht einfach
in dem Standard gebaut wurde, wie es hätte getan werden sollen oder saniert wurde.
Was ja im Prinzip der Auslöser der ganzen Proteste war das findet sich ja dann
jetzt an dieser Stelle auch wieder also gucke mal hier,
der Staat funktioniert nicht in seinen, ja in den grundlegendsten Dienstleistungen
was ja eigentlich immer der Vertrag ist ihr macht irgendwie euer Ding,
aber Hauptsache der Laden läuft und es geht halbwegs gerecht zu,
aber wenn dann halt noch nicht mal die Feuerwehr,
funktioniert, dann brückelt natürlich alles.
Absolut, absolut. Und das tatsächlich, würde ich sagen, hat sehr viele Ressourcen,
sehr viel Kraft einfach gebunden.
Und das war so ein bisschen, wo ich gemerkt habe, diese Aktion von Zivilges
und Ungehorsam, die nehmen so
ein bisschen ab. Sie sind nicht mehr so massiv, wie sie am Anfang waren.
Und man muss auch dazu sagen, ja, kam jetzt der Juli, also wir sind jetzt im Juli mittendrin.
Die Leute waren natürlich auch, also irgendwann, es kostet ja einfach Energie, das heißt,
über ein halbes Jahr sind die einfach auf der Straße und organisieren sich und
investieren Zeit und Kraft und hast schon merkt, wie so ein bisschen die Luft
dann da noch raus ist und habe gedacht, okay, es wird vielleicht so ein,
also es war auch ein bisschen so eine Befürchtung, dass dann vielleicht dieser,
Druck ablässt, weil eine Parole, die seit Monaten oder relativ früh skandiert
wurde, ist immer, Pumpe, das heißt Druck aufrechterhalten, Weil klar,
wenn der Druck erstmal nachlässt, dann kann es dort zusammenbrechen.
Das heißt, du musst immer den Druck konstant oben halten.
Und dann, als die Sorge da war, okay,
jetzt könnte im Endeffekt dieser Druck doch nachlassen, hat dann der Vucic letzten
Endes die Repression hochgefahren,
die Gewalt hochgefahren und eigentlich dann diesen Druck wieder selbst erhöht
durch diese massive Gewalt, die im Endeffekt da ausgelöst wurde.
Das heißt, es fing an, irgendwann Mitte August würde ich sagen, dass ...
Auf so Aktionen, es waren kleinere, verschiedene Aktionen, ich habe ja gesagt,
diese Bürgerversammlungen, die waren tatsächlich konstant überall mit verschiedensten
Performances, Aktionen und Protesten unterwegs,
mal kleiner, mal größer, das heißt, hat nie aufgehört und dann hat er angefangen,
Schläger-Truppen hinzuschicken und meine These ist, dass er einfach dieses Sommerloch
nutzen wollte, weil einfach dann die,
Fakultäten teilweise auch dann Lehrer waren, weil die Studenten nach Hause gefahren
sind, um mal durchzuatmen zu ihren Familien, auch an den Urlaub gefahren und so weiter,
das heißt, und er wollte, glaube ich, meiner nah und nach dieses Loch,
also die Städte waren, die großen Städte waren leer, wollte einfach nutzen,
um einfach dann jetzt vielleicht mal so richtig hart durchzugreifen,
weil er wusste, jetzt können nicht alle sofort auf die Straße gehen,
weil einfach wieder auch nicht da sind.
Und hat dann angefangen, eine andere Strategie zu fahren, dass dann auf einmal
so Schläger-Truppen aufgetaucht sind und dann Leute angegriffen haben und massiv
irgendwie angegangen haben und dann einzuschüchtern.
Und dann war es aber so, dass diese Schläger-Truppen und dieses Einschüchtern
wieder nach hinten losgingen, weil die Leute sich solidarisch gezeigt haben
und dann gesagt haben, das kann nicht sein. Und am nächsten Tag halt deutlich mehr dastanden.
Und dann bei Aktionen, wo jetzt einfach nur 50, 60 Leute da waren,
schon auf einmal mehrere tausend Leute da, weil die gesagt haben,
das kann ich hier angehen.
Genauso auch irgendwelche Läden irgendwie überfallen wurden.
Beim nächsten Tag mehrere tausend Menschen da haben die im Laden eingekauft,
dem Geld gegeben und so weiter.
Das heißt, das ist eine massive Solidarität erzeugt bei jeder Aktion,
die da durchgeführt wurde.
Und das tatsächlich dann von Ort zu Ort hat natürlich dementsprechend nochmal
die Leute so zusammen geschweißt.
Das heißt, du hast dann echt gemerkt, wie in manchen Orten auf einmal so eine,
unfassbar starke Zivilgesellschaft sich gegründet hat oder auch so entstanden
ist, wo du gesehen hast, das kannst du nicht niederknüppeln.
Da musst du schon ein Militär eigentlich hinschicken.
Du musst die ganze Stadt anzünden. Das heißt, das war jetzt nicht irgendwie
eine kleine Gruppe. Es war wirklich alle, stand auf der Straße.
Da gab es zum Beispiel Ujizeh als Beispiel.
Da gab es echt auch so Szenen, die auch wieder einen Meme-Charakter hatten.
Wo auch Leute verhaftet wurden und dann eben alle auf die Straße sind und dann
haben die versucht, die Straße zu blockieren, die Polizisten sind hier hinten rum,
weil die die Wege nicht kannten und dann haben die dann einmal in Užice war,
glaube ich, auch so, dass die versucht haben, so die Polizisten,
die von außen eingefahren wurden, nochmal, die kennen die ja Leute ja nicht,
haben dann versucht, die Straße zu blockieren und das haben die durchbrochen,
durch die Menschenmenge, die haben es einfach durchgejagt,
und da hat einer von hinten so geschrien, Užice und es war so ein bisschen wie bei diesen,
bei 300, bei dem Film, bei diesem Sparta, ja.
Und es ging dann so als Meme durch dieses Netz.
Und immer wieder Ujizeh wird genannt mit dem Audio-Snippet.
Also Ujizeh heißt was?
Ujizeh ist ein Ort, ist ein Stadt. Und das ist natürlich auch so eine Festung des Widerstands.
Und es gibt viele so Festungen des Widerstands. Die sehe ich jetzt auch, Czajac und Waljebo.
Und in all diesen Orten, wo viele Proteste vorher waren, Bürgerinnen viele Proteste
gemacht haben, haben die besonders hart durchgegriffen. Das ist für mich im
Rückblick nochmal klar geworden, weil ich so durchgegangen bin,
so was, wo große Proteste waren.
Und da habe ich schon gesehen, es war wie so eine Abrechnung mit der Zivilgesellschaft.
Das heißt, da jetzt, wo besonders viele Proteste waren, da besonders hart durchzugreifen.
Und da ist es natürlich so, dass eben so eine völlig schräge Entwicklung stattgefunden
hat, was zum einen, also Punkt eins war Schläger-Truppen tauchen auf,
dann war es so, dass Polizei kommt, aber Schläger-Truppen schützt,
dann haben die Schläger-Truppen angefangen mit dem Feuerwerk auf die Zivilgesellschaft
zu feuern, also auch völlig schräge Nummer, das hat da begonnen,
so im August irgendwann war das, glaube ich.
Und dann haben die irgendwann die Polizei die nicht mehr geschützt.
Dann sind die auf die los.
Dann gab es eine Kombi von Polizei und Schlägertruppen, wo du auch in manchen
Städten nicht wusstest.
Teilweise gibt es auch Videos, wo die miteinander gesprochen haben.
Wo du auch nicht unterscheiden konntest, ist das jetzt die Schlägertruppe von
dem Regime oder ist in dem Fall jetzt ein Polizist.
Zumal auch dann aufgekommen ist, dass er eben auch so Spezialeinheiten hat,
die eben auch als Zivil unterwegs sind.
Also eine Polizeispezialeinheit, aber die gar nicht irgendwie unterscheiden
kannst von so einem klassischen Schläger.
Das heißt, die haben sich auch nicht ausgezeichnet oder irgendwie Marken gezeigt.
Die haben die zwei wieder nur T-Shirts gehabt oder gar nicht dabei gehabt.
Also es war eine völlig schräge Kiste und man hat tatsächlich auch hochgefahren,
auch diese Einschüchterung ist mir aufgefallen, ging über junge Menschen speziell.
Das heißt, wir haben Verhaftungen gehabt, die zugenommen haben,
aber auch so, das Framing von den Studenten fand ich sehr gut,
die haben angefangen, von Kidnapping zu sprechen.
Weil du musst dir vorstellen, in Belgien gab es eine Szene, da fährt ein schwarzes
Auto vor, Typ ins Vieh steigt aus, packt einen 15, 14-Jährigen ins Auto und wir fahren mit dem weg.
Und die Mutter schreit und so weiter und dann denkst du, was ist das jetzt, was war da jetzt?
Offiziell ist das ein legitimer Vorgang, das heißt ein Polizist nimmt die mit,
aber im Endeffekt war nichts davon legitim, das heißt erstmal bei Minderjährigen
müssen Eltern mit dabei sein, das heißt es gibt so Sachen, die auch in Serbien
eigentlich angehalten werden müssen.
Also nicht nur nicht legitim, auch nicht legal.
Nicht legal, genau, richtig. Nicht legal, Entschuldigung.
Und dann kannst du dir vorstellen, Diese Aktionen wurden immer mehr und mehr,
bis hin zu, dass es tatsächlich auch so Szenen gab, ich glaube in Valiowars
auch dann, wo dann eben auch Jugendliche von mehreren Polizisten in voller Montur
mit Schlagstöcken bearbeitet wurden.
Das heißt, er lag da am Boden und die schlagen auf den einen,
zu zehn, zu zwölf stehen um ihn herum und kicken und so weiter.
Und dann, das natürlich kannst du dir vorstellen, was das...
Was beim Menschen ausgelöst hat. Das heißt, da waren einfach Eltern,
also wenn ich als Vater darüber nachdenke, boah.
Und dann kannst dir vorstellen, da waren die ganze Stadt, war am nächsten Tag,
also die waren dann auf der Straße.
Und natürlich, dann gab es da Demos, kannst du dir vorstellen.
Und da war wiederum die Frage, wird es jetzt eskalieren, wird es nicht eskalieren?
Im Endeffekt ist es nicht eskaliert. Also im Sinne von,
dass jetzt die auf die Polizei los sind und es ist ein bisschen eine komplexe
Geschichte, weil wiederum Und es wurde genutzt, diese Demo, die dann da gab,
um wiederum ein Bild von den gewaltsamen Zivilgesellschaften zu zeichnen,
weil im Endeffekt war von Beginn an das Interesse und die Idee von Vucic eigentlich,
diese friedlichen, friedvollen Proteste irgendwie anders zu framen.
Und deswegen war von Beginn an, die sich mit den Schläger-Truppen hinschicken
und dann die Leute zu irritieren oder im Endeffekt dieses Bild,
was da ist, eben zu stören, das war das Ziel.
Und natürlich kannst du dir vorstellen, wo die Proteste an waren.
Haben die angefangen, zum Beispiel sind sie zu SNS-Gebäuden gegangen und haben
manche Eier drauf geworfen und an manchen Stellen wurden die angezündet und demoliert.
Und auch da wiederum ist nicht klar. Also ich habe aus verschiedenen Quellen
wiederum, wo Leute sagen, ich komme aus dem Ort, ich kann die Leute nicht,
die da waren, die es gemacht haben.
Und die Leute, die aus dem Ort sind, die würden nie, also zum Beispiel wurde
auch einmal von der Stadt irgendwie was angezündet, von der Staatsanwaltschaft,
glaube ich, oder Gerichtsgebäude und so.
Und da hat die eine Reporterin gesagt, ich lebe hier, wieso sollte ich ein Interesse
daran haben, dass etwas von der Stadt, was ich mitfinanziere,
was ich zeige, ist meine Stadt, dass das kaputt gehen soll. Niemand von den
Bürgern hier wird das tun.
Das heißt, es gab schon für mich überzeugende, gute Argumente,
was dafür sprechen würde, dass es wiederum eben Fremdkörper waren,
die das initiiert haben, um wieder die Bilder zu zeugen, schau,
die gewaltsamen Proteste, die tatsächlich auch medial genauso kommuniziert wurden.
Das war das Irre, was ich dann hier in Deutschland kritisiert habe und zum Glück
irgendwann dann korrigiert wurde, dass ja auch in Deutschland in Tagesschau
und anderen Nachrichten angefangen zu erzählen.
Die Proteste werden jetzt gewaltsam in Serbien. Dass man davon gesprochen hat,
oh, die Zivilgesellschaft, also von Wien ausgehend, geht die Gewalt aus.
Dabei war es nie der Fall.
Und es gab tatsächlich bis heute, es gibt nicht einen einzigen Protest,
wo zur Gewalt aufgerufen wurde oder Leute gesagt haben, wir wollen da jetzt
irgendwie, oder die Gewalt von denen ausgehen.
Das heißt, es war immer eine Reaktion auf eine Gewalt, die sie erfahren haben,
wenn es Gewalt im Endeffekt gab.
Und an vielen, vielen Stellen, noch einmal, man schlägt eigentlich immer noch
nicht zurück. Ich habe tatsächlich x Beispiele, wo die einfach verprügelt wurden
und es hingenommen haben letzten Endes und gesagt haben, alles was ich jetzt
fordere ist, ich fordere ein, dass jetzt der Rechtsweg eingeschritten wird.
Das heißt, dass die Polizei Leute verhaftet, dass die Gerichte ihren Job machen,
das machen die bis konsequent bis heute.
Und deswegen ärgert mich so ein bisschen, dass es doch gelungen ist,
letzten Endes, über diese Strategie, die ja im Prinzip verfolgt hat.
Teilweise dieses Bild zu zeichnen von, es sind gewaltsame Proteste.
Und auch bei manchen Bürgerinnen, habe ich tatsächlich in Gesprächen auf mich
rausgehört, die dann auch gesagt haben, naja, die sind jetzt auch gefrusterte
Leute, das heißt, es kam auch bei manchen Leuten, die das jetzt vielleicht,
selbst aus den Reihen der Studentinnen und Zivilgesellschaft stammen,
auch das Bild entstanden ist, naja, im Endeffekt die Leute langsam sauer und
jetzt wollen sie doch Gewalt anwenden.
Aber der Punkt eben, gewaltlos zu bleiben, ist eigentlich ein wesentlicher,
ein fundamentaler bei den ganzen Protesten.
Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, inwiefern das allen klar ist.
Weil letzten Endes geht es darum, wie du einen Regimewechsel erreichst,
prägt die Gesellschaft, die danach kommt.
Das heißt, wenn mit Gewalt etwas stürzt, dann hast du einfach,
was soll danach, was soll auf diesen Zement, Was soll auf diesem Boden denn
wachsen, wenn der mit Gewalt in dem Fall erschaffen wurde?
Und deswegen, auch wenn es jetzt natürlich jetzt sehr religiert,
von sehr, sehr weit entfernt kommuniziert ist von mir, ist aber politisch,
soziologisch und so weiter betrachtet tatsächlich eigentlich sehr,
sehr sinnvoll, weiterhin bei diesen gewaltfreien Protesten zu bleiben.
Und das auf diesen anderen Weg einfach zu erreichen, dass dieses Regime einfach
gestürzt wird und im Endeffekt dann bestenfalls neue Wahlen oder gerechte Wahlen
in der demokratischen Gesellschaft etablieren können.
Ich meine, das ist ja schon sehr faszinierend zu sehen, dass es überhaupt so
lange dieses Mantra beibehalten hat, weil ich meine, es ist ja klar,
wenn du da so eine riesige Protestbewegung hast, gerade junge Leute, die dann sehen,
jetzt stehe ich hier seit acht Monaten, protestiere und nichts ändert sich so
in meiner einfachen Wahrnehmung, auch wenn sie vielleicht Dinge ändern,
aber dann vielleicht nicht so schnell oder so umfangreich, wie man sich das
dann so vorgestellt hat.
Dass es bei manchen dann einfach irgendwann auch mal so eine Sicherung durchgeht
und die sagen so, das hat jetzt alles keinen Sinn mehr, hier,
ich hau da jetzt einfach drauf, ich will jetzt alles nur noch brennen sehen.
Das ist ja not unheard of.
Andererseits ist es wahrscheinlich auch genau etwas, worauf Vucic letzten Endes setzt.
So nach dem Motto, protestiert ihr mal, irgendwann werdet ihr durchdrehen und
jetzt schicke ich hier auch nochmal ein paar Rüpel mit ins Feld und triggere
das vielleicht dann auch nochmal, irgendwann werden wir euch schon so diskreditiert bekommen.
Und tatsächlich so in diesem Wikipedia-Artikel, und das ist auch das,
was mir so sofort aufgefallen ist, war genau dieses Framing so überall mit drin.
So, ja, hier ist ein Dekan an der Hochschule angegriffen worden und dann wurden
die Reifen zerstochen von einem Krankenwagen, obwohl er ja gerade kollabiert
ist und dann konnte er nicht ins Krankenhaus gefahren werden.
Also so die ganze Zeit so Storys mit, ja, ganz böse hier die Proteste und die
Polizei hat dann aber dann doch wieder alles in den Griff bekommen,
sodass es dann irgendwie alles wieder gut war.
Also immer so dieses Märchen oder diese Geschichten von der gute Staat,
der sich ja nur darum kümmert, dass jetzt hier irgendwie alles Law and Order bleibt.
Was sicherlich bei vielen Leuten dann auch irgendwie ankommt,
wenn das eben die einzige Nachrichtenernährung ist, die sie haben.
Es ist tatsächlich eigentlich aus der Entfernung betrachtet,
ich glaube für Soziologinnen ist es, glaube ich,
fantastisch, was man da beobachten kann, wenn man einfach die allen Stimmen
sich anhört, du kannst eigentlich sehen, wie Gesellschaft einfach laut nachdenkt
über all das, was passiert und ich höre tatsächlich sehr, sehr unterschiedliche
Stimmen einfach, also das, was du gesagt hast, die Stimmen gibt es,
aber es gibt auch Stimmen, die sagen,
pass auf, wir haben von Beginn an gesagt, das ist ein Marathon und das ist eben
nicht etwas, was jetzt sofort passiert.
Ich verstehe natürlich, dass man den schnellen Wandel haben möchte,
aber wir müssen da einfach beharrlich bleiben.
Und ich habe schon das Gefühl, dass diese Stimmen jetzt nicht wenig Zuspruch bekommen.
Ich glaube schon, dass vielen klar ist, es geht einfach nicht von heute auf
morgen und das einfach ein Prozess ist.
Und vor allem auch mit der Debatte, die ich an manchen Stellen gehört habe.
Manchen Stellen wird eine Debatte eröffnet, was passiert denn?
Jetzt gehen wir davon aus, wir hätten jetzt neue Wahlen.
Gehen wir davon aus, wir würden die gewinnen und gehen wir davon aus,
er würde die anerkennen, dass er verloren hat. Gehen wir von einem Best-Szenario aus, was dann?
Und dann stellst du schon fest, hey, es sind eigentlich massive,
enorme, große, komplexe Baustellen, die man angehen muss.
Und dann wird wiederum nochmal klarer, wie lang und wie komplex und wie schwer
der ganze Prozess ist, eigentlich als demokratische Gesellschaft irgendwo anzukommen.
Oder zumindest auf so einen Punkt zu kommen, wo ich sagen würde,
jetzt kann man von einer demokratischen Gesellschaft im Endeffekt sprechen.
Und drum ist es, glaube ich, schon so ein Aspekt, wo ich das Gefühl habe,
dass für Monat für Monat dieser Prozess auch bei Leuten einfach so langsam klar ist.
Also vielleicht kann man es auch diesen Neuwahlen leicht so verstehen.
Ich habe eine Professorin,
der, ich glaube, der Philosophischenfakultät oder der Politikfassenschaft,
ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, die hat gesagt, dass sie im Dezember,
Januar schon gesagt hat, es bräuchte Neuwahlen.
Aber das hat sie jetzt aber nicht gesagt, weil sie wusste, es bringt nichts.
Auch wenn ich weiß, dass es richtig ist, dass das passieren muss,
das müssen die Studentinnen für sich verstehen.
Das heißt, den Prozess, den kann ich für die nicht verkürzen.
Die müssen für sich den Prozess durchlaufen, verstehen an einem gewissen Punkt,
es führt nichts an Wahlen vorbei.
Und dann hat es einfach eine andere Legitimität, einen anderen Impact,
ein anderes Verständnis, was einfach dann von denen auch getragen wird,
was ihr Verständnis ist. Die haben den Prozess durchlaufen.
Und das ist für mich so ein Punkt, den man vielleicht auch gesellschaftlich
so die Parallele ziehen kann.
Man kann das jetzt nicht beschleunigen. Auch wenn man weiß, was danach kommen
müsste, trotzdem müssen die, glaube ich, die Leute diesen Prozess durchlaufen
und verstehen, an welchen Stellen ich zum Beispiel auch beharrlich bleiben muss
und weiter engagieren muss.
Weil es ist eigentlich auch der Punkt, dass Leute gesagt haben,
ob jetzt bei Studentinnen oder bei Zwiegesellschaft.
Wir müssen es auch schaffen, auch wenn wir den Punkt erreicht hätten,
dass wir ein neues System haben und eine neue Regierung hätten,
die vielleicht demokratisch gewählt wäre.
Müssen wir weiter eigentlich als Gesellschaft schaffen, dass wir diese kritische
Masse, diese kritisch denkenden Menschen, diese Diversität, dass wir die weiterhin haben.
Das heißt, dass die nächste Regierung, die an der Macht ist,
genauso kritisch betrachtet wird von diesen gleichen Organisationen und Zusammenkünften,
Bündnissen, die es aber gibt, die jetzt da sind.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt das zu überführen in den Alltag hinein.
Das heißt, das, was du jetzt gewonnen hast, das musst du aufrechterhalten.
Und ich glaube, dass es immer mehr Leuten klar ist,
dass dieses, du bist eigentlich Teil von Gesellschaft, du formst Gesellschaft
und du musst jetzt am Ball bleiben, es wird halt immer anstrengend bleiben,
weil Demokratie halt anstrengend ist und ich glaube, dass das etwas ist,
was so langsam einfach so bei Leuten so einsickert und die verstehen und deswegen
bin ich tatsächlich an manchen Stellen,
denke ich, boah, voll gut und an manchen Tagen denke ich, boah,
alles geht den Bach runter und ich glaube, so ähnlich geht es den Leuten auch,
du hast so Schwankungen zwischen,
ach, alles Kacke und boah, es wird voll gut.
Dann gibt es noch so einen Namen, Marco Kritschak, der eine gewisse Rolle spielt
in diesem ganzen Komplex.
Ja, er spielt insofern eine Rolle. Es gab bei Demos in Belgrad,
gab es eben den Punkt, dass er Leute,
also er ist einmal, muss man zusagen, sowieso eine Personalie,
die sehr, sehr umstritten ist und lange diskutiert wird.
Er ist eigentlich Autoverkäufer, gelernte Autoverkäufer und hat im Endeffekt,
soviel ich weiß, in so einem Porsche, Mercedes irgendwie Laden,
wo dann vom Staat die Fahrzeuge geprüft werden, als Service durchgeführt wird,
hat er gearbeitet und wurde da von einer Person aus dem Regime eben akquiriert
und wurde dann erstmal, glaube ich, in diese,
ja sowas wie ähnlich wie BND, also ähnliche BND geholt als staatlicher Mitarbeiter
und wird dann später irgendwie hoch nochmal.
Mal, ist in der Leiter gestiegen und wird dann direkt Leiter von so einer Einheit,
die eigentlich für Person und.
Gebäudeschutz zuständig ist. Das heißt, wenn ihr auf Gebäude gesichert werden
müsst, Personen gesichert werden müsst, dann ist dann diese Spezialeinheit dafür zuständig.
So kann man es im Endeffekt runterbrechen. Es war eine relativ überschaubare
Einheit und der hat tatsächlich aus ihr was völlig anderes formiert in einer relativ kurzen Zeit.
Das heißt, er hat einfach dann mehrere tausend Mitarbeiter, es waren vor ein
paar hundert, Hat so mehreren tausend Mitarbeiter im Prinzip eben dann entwickeln
lassen, die unter seiner Hand sind.
Und man kann es eigentlich, also die Expertinnen beschreiben,
diese Spezialeinheit als Polizei in der Polizei.
Das heißt, die hat wohl schon sehr viel zu sagen, hat sehr viele Freiheiten.
Und letzten Endes musst du überlegen, was das Wutschitsch-Regime macht seit
sehr vielen, vielen Monaten, dass sie überall die seriösen,
guten Leute an solchen Positionen ersetzen gegen Regime, treue Menschen,
die in der Regel nicht qualifiziert dafür sind.
Und was wir darum für das ganze Korruption-Thema spricht, das heißt,
du hast einfach, egal wo, auch irgendwie Betrieben, Unternehmen,
hast du Menschen, die einfach ein Diplom gekauft haben oder einfach,
also das heißt, die Expertise nicht gar nicht mitbringen, aber einfach alles
irgendwie dann anders geregelt haben über die Partei, über die Kohle.
Und der Typ ist einfach auch, also musst du dir vorstellen, leitet Spezialeinheiten,
eine Spezialeinheit und hat nicht mal eine ganze Menge Polizeiausbildung durchlaufen.
Das heißt, normal hast du diese ganzen Tests, auch psychologische Tests und
physische und sonstige Tests und so weiter, weil natürlich jemand,
der eben exklusiv Gewalt hat, auch Gewalt ausüben darf, kann nicht einfach jeder machen.
Das heißt, da musst du einfach gewisse, da darfst du zum Beispiel nicht sofort
ausrasten. Das heißt, wenn du nicht schlecht und ein bisschen sachlich und kühl
im Kopf beraten könntest, in Situationen diskalierend wirken kannst,
also gewisse Kompetenzen müsst ihr eigentlich in den Polizeikräften mitbringen
und dementsprechend hast du auch gewisse Schulungen, die durchlaufen müssen.
Und je höher du steigst, umso qualifizierter und besser muss die ganzen Sachen im Endeffekt ja sein.
Und da haben wir am Ende nochmal einen Typen, der eigentlich Autoverkäufer ist
und auf einmal diese Spezialeinheit leitet und aber natürlich sehr, sehr regimetreu ist.
Und der hat, letzten Endes hat sich tatsächlich bekannt, ist bekannt geworden,
dass er immer mehr auch bei Demos aufgetreten ist.
Das heißt, mit irgendwelchen Leuten, die in Zivil rumgelaufen sind und Leute festgehalten wurden.
Also bei Demos, um aufzutauchen, was zu bewachen und so weiter,
ist eigentlich nicht sein Themengebiet.
Noch einmal ist eigentlich Personenschutz und Gebäudeschutz und dann gab es
da schon die ersten Geschichten, wo dann kursiert sind, dass Leute verhaftet wurden und so.
Und jetzt ist er nochmal so in die Schlagzeilen geraten, weil eben es gab bei
der Demo in Belgrad, wurden Leute verhaftet, verprügelt, tot gedroht,
Vergewaltigung gedroht.
Alles innerhalb der Regierungsgebäude, das ist eine Garage der Regierung,
wo scheinbar keine Aufnahmen existieren, weshalb auch immer.
Weil in so einem Gebäude eigentlich immer überall alle Kameras laufen.
Das heißt, so ein Regierungsbäude hat einfach gewisse Auflagen,
auch Sicherheitsmaßnahmen.
Das heißt, die ganzen Materialien sind leider nicht da.
Deswegen kann man dem auch nicht nachgehen. Deswegen ist er jetzt heute immer
noch weiter auf freiem Fuß, obwohl gegen geklagt wurde.
Aber der springende Punkt ist, eine Studentin, zum Beispiel Nicolina,
die hat jetzt tatsächlich auch jetzt die Schlagzeilen gemacht,
die wurde eben auch verlieben.
Kopf gegen die Wand gestoßen und geschlagen und hat eben dann ihr gedroht,
dass er vergewaltigen wird von allen und irgendwelche Sachen irgendwo hinstecken wird und so weiter.
Übelste, irgendwie Angst eingejagt, beschimpft und beleidigt und es waren mehrere
Personen da mit anwesend, die auch verhaftet wurden, die es mitbekommen haben und so weiter.
Und jetzt kann man sich ja vorstellen, was wäre also die Idee von ihm oder vom Regime.
Diese Menschen gehen eingeschüchtert nach Hause und die lassen sich nie wieder blicken.
Sie ist aber an die Öffentlichkeit alles erzählt. Ist ins Fernsehen,
haben andere Studenten auch gemacht.
Ins Fernsehen erzählt, was ihnen passiert ist, wie der eine Student hat erzählt,
dass eben festgenommen wurde, der Typ gesagt hat, ich schieße dir jetzt den Kopf und so weiter.
Also, der hat mal erzählt, was sie erlebt haben, was sie durchlaufen haben.
Und dieses Erzählen, Sichtbarmachen ist tatsächlich wiederum etwas,
was die Studenten sehr klug machen, sehr gut machen.
Das heißt, diese Intransparenz wird einfach, also, oder Dinge werden einfach
gelüftet und transparent aufgezeigt und man weiß einfach, aufgrund der Fülle der Berichte,
dass da einfach was dran ist und dementsprechend ist dann entfaltet statt dieser
Einschüchterung ist eher dieses entfalze was völlig anderes.
Das heißt, dass die so mutig sind, also es gab natürlich eine Demo auch ein
paar Tage später, wo dann die sogar vor dem Gebäude dieser Spezialeinheit eine Rede gehalten hat.
Und du musst dir vorstellen, was hatten die schäbigerweise gemacht?
Die haben vor dem Gebäude, haben sie blockiert, dass niemand reinkommen kann
von dieser Spezialeinheit, von dem Gebäude, wo sie drin sind und haben drei,
vier Frauen hingestellt.
Also absolut schäbig nach dem Motto, ja erstens ich weiß nicht,
was damit kommuniziert werden soll nach dem Motto, wir haben auch Frauen,
wir sind nicht gegen Frauen, auch Frauen, also irgendwie so in die Richtung,
plus selber natürlich, weißt, sich zurückziehen, keine Verantwortung nehmen,
sondern dann solche Leute in die erste Reihe schicken. Also absolut schäbig.
Und da tatsächlich sind auch wiederum Debatten entstanden, wieso das so war
und wie die Frauen dazustehen, dass sie arbeiten können und so weiter.
Aber ich fand es tatsächlich sehr, sehr bewundernswert, sehr mutig und tatsächlich
sehr, sehr ein starkes Zeichen auch, dass Menschen sich eben nicht einschüchtern
lassen und sagen, hey, egal was es kostet, Wir machen weiter, wir machen weiter.
Und das ist tatsächlich so eine Geschichte, die mit einem Fall Kritschak verbunden ist.
Zum einen zu sehen, wie ein korruptes System dazu führt, dass Menschen an Positionen
sind, für die sie nicht eine Expertise aufbringen.
Aber im Endeffekt alles, was ich mitbringe, ist einfach eine blinde Loyalität
bis zum Schluss und tatsächlich vor nichts zurückschrecken, das heißt also auch
bereit sind, alles zu machen, was gemacht werden muss,
bis hin zu, auf der anderen Seite, Menschen, die einfach sagen,
ich nehme alles, was passiert.
Alles, was passiert, kann mich nicht einschüchtern, das heißt,
wir gehen für eine gerechte Sache auf die Straße und im Endeffekt sogar andersrum,
die hat ihn gedroht, wird gesagt, irgendwann wirst du zur Rechenschaft gezogen, was da passiert ist.
Und das finde ich schon eigentlich, Das spiegelt, finde ich,
relativ viel wieder, weil du einfach siehst, wir reden jetzt von Ende August,
also das heißt, sehr, sehr langer Zeitraum mit all den Hochs und Tiefs und wo du merkst,
die Leute sind sehr beharrlich, die sind sehr klar und sehr deutlich,
was sie haben wollen und auch die Professorinnen, die Dekaninnen,
die Universität wird ja auch tatsächlich massiv angegriffen,
auch diese sehr, sehr klare Kommunikation und sagen, es gibt hier kein Zurück.
Das ist die Botschaft der letzten Wochen.
Das Einzige, was geklärt werden muss, ist, wie er geht, wie das System,
wie das Regime geht und wann.
Das heißt, das ist wie und wann ist im Endeffekt noch ein Fragezeichen.
Aber dass das passieren wird, ist allen klar.
Trotzdem wehrt sich Vucic weiterhin mit allen möglichen Maßnahmen und Einschüchterungen.
Also wenn ich das richtig sehe, gab es ja dann noch verschiedene Maßnahmen,
wo Gemeinden Geld entzogen wurde und auch ansonsten Unternehmen privatisiert wurde.
Was ist denn Vucic alles noch so eingefallen, wie er jetzt hier gegensteuern kann in seinem Sinne?
Ja, also neben der Repression in Form von Gewalt, die im Prinzip auf den Straßen
sich niederschlägt, macht er natürlich auch finanziell massiven Druck,
politisch massiven Druck.
Das heißt, er hat angefangen eben, also es gab tatsächlich so nach unserem letzten
Podcast, fing er an, Gehälter zu kürzen oder gar nicht aufzuzahlen.
Das heißt, die Leute in dem Bildungswesen,
Keine Gelder bekommen nach dem Motto, wer protestiert und keinen Unterricht
hält oder lehrt und so weiter, arbeitet ja auch nicht, bekommt auch dementsprechend kein Geld.
Andere Gelder wurden auch nicht ausgezahlt in Hochschulen. Das heißt sowas wie,
wo ich im Endeffekt dann sowieso, also tatsächlich, wo ich verpflichtet wäre
als Staat eigentlich das zu zahlen.
Also zum Beispiel die Gebäuderechnung, also das Strom und Wasser und so weiter
bezahlen kann. Also all diese ganzen Mittel wurden nicht ausgezahlt.
Es ist ganz, ganz viel, also in diesem finanziellen Sektor wurde Druck ausgeübt auf Professorinnen.
Es gibt tatsächlich heute noch Fakultäten, wo Professorinnen bis heute noch
keinen einzigen Cent überwiesen bekommen haben.
Ich habe tatsächlich erst vor kurzem, vor ein paar Tagen mit einem Professor
gesprochen, der an der Auslöser Fakultät arbeitet, auch jemand,
der heute jetzt kein Gehalt bekommt seit x Monaten.
Das heißt, du hast einmal diesen finanziellen Druck und genauso auch nicht nur
bei Universitäten und bei Lehrkräften, auch jetzt auch bei Gemeinden.
Das heißt, diesen Nobipasar hast du jetzt genannt, wird tatsächlich auch für
den ganzen August dieses Budget, was ausgezahlt werden müsste,
hat dann der Budget gesagt, nö, bekommen die nicht, um einfach wiederum die
abzustrafen, weil es auch eben massive Proteste gab seitens der BürgerInnen
und da gab es tatsächlich auch den Versuch,
die Fakultät zu besetzen, gewaltsam zu besetzen, das heißt, du hast vorhin,
dass du dazu berichtet hast, von dem Wiederbeitrag, das war der erste Versuch,
das war im April, Ende April, es war in Novi Sad, in der Sportfakultät hat der Typ versucht eben,
ein Dekan war das, der hat versucht so ein bisschen mit Polizeikräften das ein
bisschen zu stürmen und zu gucken, was passiert und ist natürlich voll nach
hinten losgegangen, die haben es nicht geschafft und jetzt in Novi Passat war
jetzt tatsächlich so der nächste Schritt, wo es wieder versucht hat,
ist wieder gescheitert, das heißt, sie haben es wieder dann eben befreit mit
massiver Zivilgesellschaft, die gekommen ist und unterstützt hat und die Polizeikräfte weggedrängt hat,
und dann ist tatsächlich aber jetzt im, danach jetzt im,
ich muss gucken, wann das nochmal war, ich glaube im August,
Ende August wurde in Novi Sad die Fakultät besetzt, die philosophische.
Und da ist tatsächlich der Punkt, also rechtlich ist es so.
Von wem jetzt?
Von Polizeikräften, aber jetzt kommt der springende Punkt. Rechtlich hast du
als Dekan, hast du wie das Hausrecht über deine Fakultät, über das Gebäude.
Und im Endeffekt können die nicht kommen, ohne dass der Dekan die ruft.
Und da hat im Endeffekt der Dekan sie gerufen, vom Philosophischen Fakultät
hat im Endeffekt über Nacht da die ganzen,
Leute, Studentinnen rausgeworfen und hat im Endeffekt das Gebäude mit Polizeikräften
befüllt und da gab es eben massive Proteste weil eben nicht klar war,
was ist da los, wie kann das sein und da hat er gesagt er fühlt sich irgendwie.
Nicht sicher und da gab es eine massive Irritation gab es Demonstrationen vorm
Haus was wiederum zu Gewalt geführt hat das Rektorat wurde besetzt und der Rektorat
Also noch einmal der Uni Novisat hat auch wiederum die Polizeikräfte gerufen
und deswegen durften die da auch reinkommen,
haben da wieder Leute besetzt und noch mit der Presse irgendwie sind sehr,
sehr schräg umgegangen.
Also letzten Endes ist tatsächlich so der Punkt, der versucht die Hochschulgemeinde
eigentlich auseinander zu dividieren.
Das heißt, ich habe am Anfang, letztes Mal, glaube ich, erklärt,
dass eine tragende Kraft, eine tragende Säule der Protest ist Solidarität und Bündnisse.
Und was er natürlich versucht, weil er einfach natürlich dann Profis in dem
Bereich, überall irgendwo Leute auseinanderzubekommen.
Über finanziellen Druck, über politischen Druck.
Das heißt, bei dem Prorektor zum Beispiel, wie ich sagt, bin mir nicht sicher.
Da gibt Cousin so Geschichten, dass er im Endeffekt auch persönlich eingeschüchtert
wurde und dann dementsprechend ist es dann so legitimen musste,
dass die da kommen und so weiter.
Das heißt, dann hat er zum Beispiel auch eine Dekanin von der medizinischen
Fakultät in Belgrad auch abgesetzt, rechtswidrig.
Das heißt, das Gremium, was es abgesetzt hat, das darf es gar nicht oder die
Personen, dürfen sie gar nicht, weil es wiederum dazu geführt hat,
dass die neu besetzt wurde mit einer anderen Person.
Aber die Hochschulgemeinschaft agiert da, finde ich jetzt aktuell gerade sehr solidarisch.
Aber letzten Endes, was ich sagen möchte, hat versucht, überall so einen Pflock,
reinzureihen zwischen den Leuten Auch tatsächlich zwischen Studentinnen und Professorinnen.
Das heißt zum Beispiel hat er angefangen, eben diesen Druck zu erhöhen,
diesen finanziellen und hat gesagt, wenn die eine Online-Lehre beginnen oder
irgendeine Form von Lehre, dann bekommen sie Geld.
Und haben tatsächlich dann angefangen, Professorinnen-Online-Lehre durchzuführen.
Und dann gab es wieder Megadiskurse zwischen Studentinnen und Professorinnen,
sehr kontrovers geführt.
Letzten Endes, ich habe tatsächlich in deutschen Medien gelesen,
dass gesagt wurde, dass die Unis, die Blockaden nicht mehr existieren,
die Unis würden ganz mal laufen.
Das ist falsch, das stimmt so nicht.
Das heißt, es gibt tatsächlich, ich habe extra mal den Prof gefragt,
der gemeint, im Endeffekt ist es so gewesen,
dass Hochschulen angefangen, Online-Lehre und so dieses Ergänzen des Studiums.
Anzubieten, um die Gelder zu bekommen.
Das heißt, man war eine Simulation von Lehre, um Gelder zu bekommen,
den Druck einfach rauszunehmen, der finanziell einfach vorlag bei manchen.
Weil manche Professoren haben
tatsächlich angefangen, in der Gastro zu arbeiten, haben ausgeschenkt.
Weil die einfach irgendwie an Geld rankommen mussten. Also es war völlig schräge Kiste.
Und deswegen war diese Form von Lehre, die stattgefunden hat,
es war keine reguläre Lehre, es war einfach eher eine Simulation von Lehre,
um einfach diesen Druck ein bisschen finanziell rauszunehmen.
Und das war jetzt Ende Sommersemester. Das heißt jetzt, wie es im Bindersemester geht, ist völlig offen.
Das ist tatsächlich so jetzt, ich glaube zum 1. November erwartet,
wurde die Formulierung wohl die Erwartung formuliert, dass das Bindersemester
dann regulär starten soll.
Nach aktuellem Stand sind die Fakultäten immer noch in der Blockade.
Jetzt physische Blockade weiß ich nicht, weil ich gerade nicht vor Ort bin,
aber auf jeden Fall in der Blockade.
Und jetzt, ob der reguläre Studium beginnen wird, weiß ich nicht.
Und weil du gesagt hast, dieses mit dem, er versucht noch verschiedenste Sachen
Druck auszuhüben mit der Privatisierung zum Beispiel, finde ich auch einen wichtigen Aspekt.
Er hat angefangen jetzt auch zeitgleich parallel angefangen,
öffentliche Unternehmen zu privatisieren.
Das heißt zum Beispiel alles, so ein Unternehmen, was die ganze Wälder,
organisiert, ganze Waldsysteme oder Wasserkraftwerke und so weiter,
Wassersysteme oder Nationalparks, möchte er umwandeln in Aktiengesellschaften
und GmbHs und dann wiederum irgendwo auch verkaufen.
Das heißt, letztendlich versucht er einfach an Geld ranzukommen und alles zu
privatisieren, was man privatisieren kann.
Und der Punkt ist, dieses Privatisieren von allem macht er halt massiv.
Also jetzt aktuell zum Beispiel auch, habe ich jetzt gestern Nachrichten gelesen,
möchte jetzt Gebäude und Wohnungen, alles, was jetzt gebaut wurde, ohne.
Genehmigung, möchte er legalisieren über einen kleinen Betrag x.
Einen kleinen Betrag musst du zahlen und dann kriegst du legalisiert.
Das ist zwar dann im Grundbuch festgehalten, aber es ist tatsächlich rechtlich wohl so,
dass nicht irgendwo, also es ist legal, aber gewisse, also im Endeffekt ist es nicht sicher.
Also zum Beispiel, der Staat sagt laut dem Gesetz, was er wohl durchführen möchte,
dass die nicht dafür in Schutz, also die...
Die müssen den Schutz nicht oder die Sicherheit nicht gewähren.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt kannst du jetzt ein Haus bauen, illegal,
und du wirst dich jetzt legalisieren für eine kleine Summe, die dieser Staat bekommt.
Und dann sagt dir, wenn was passiert, ist dann deine Verantwortung, ich bin da raus.
Und das ist tatsächlich so die Debatte jetzt gerade aktuell,
dass versucht jetzt gerade schnell an Geld ranzukommen, zum einen,
und vielleicht auch so ein Punkt ist von, der merkt das eigentlich das Ende
naht, und versucht nochmal irgendwie an schnell an Cash ranzukommen.
Also es ist tatsächlich Debatte ist.
Komplex. Man hat die Sachlage jetzt nicht, aber zumindest sieht man,
dass das Wasser versucht ist, immer permanent, konsequent Dinge irgendwie zu verkaufen.
Und das ist ja etwas, was er seit Jahren macht, ob jetzt das Lithium und Bohr
bei allem, ob es Geschäfte mit China, Geschäfte mit Russland,
Geschäfte mit dem auch immer, geht es immer darum, dass einfach ein Gut,
was ein öffentliches Gut ist, privatisiert und dann verkauft.
Ich habe tatsächlich einen neuen Podcast gehört von so einem Rechtsexperten,
der gesagt hat, dass ein Gesetz tatsächlich vor Brutschig eingeführt wurde, völlig schräge Kiste,
wo es darum ging, um Erfassung von Wertschätzen, Bodenschätzen,
die vorliegen und dass wer da diese Forschung durchführen darf und dann Rechte
hat, Sachen zu bohren und so weiter.
Letzten Endes ist die Gesetzesänderung dazu bewirkt, dass einfach jetzt Fremdfirmen
von außen reinkommen können, irgendwo Bodenschätze, also irgendwelche Bodenschätze,
Sachen erforschen können, erkunden können und dann Rechte haben, das zu tun.
Und diese Rechte im Endeffekt übersteigen das Recht, des Privatbesitzes.
Im Endeffekt wurde tatsächlich im Jahrteil auch so vorgegangen,
dass man Leute im Endeffekt auch teilweise enteignet hat, weil man gesagt hat,
die haben laut dem Gesetz das Recht, da irgendwie wohl zu bohren.
Also völlig juristisch muss man da glaube ich das genauer sich anschauen,
aber ich war tatsächlich dann noch, habe so festgestellt, dass alles,
was so passiert, tatsächlich auch einen langen Atem hat.
Das heißt, dass das Woodshipping-Regime tatsächlich jetzt kein Zufall ist,
das so lange anhält, sondern einfach Dinge in langer Hand vorab geplant wurden
von gewissen Leuten und dementsprechend auch jetzt so lange anhalten und dementsprechend
so schwierig auch eben zu kippen sind.
Ja, ich meine, da gibt es, hatten wir glaube ich in der letzten Sendung auch
schon kurz angesprochen, also wahrscheinlich nicht nur, aber vor allem um Lithiumabbau,
was ja in Serbien da in, also wird zumindest vermutet, in größeren Mengen,
vorkommt und da Lithium gerade ein sehr begehrtes Element ist,
kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass da eine ganze Menge Geld dahinter steckt
und Das die Sache an der Stelle sicherlich nicht besser macht.
Also er versucht weiterhin Druck auszuüben.
Trotzdem gehen ja die Demonstrationen weiter, oder?
Die nehmen nicht ab und tatsächlich auch meiner Wahrnehmung nach würde ich sagen,
macht die Zivilgesellschaft jetzt noch einen viel stärkeren Job,
wobei sie zu Studenten jetzt wieder zurückkehren.
Also nach den ersten Anmeldungen hast du, die ersten Prüfungen hast du jetzt
gehabt und da hast du die neuen Jahrgänge.
Das heißt, du hast sehr aktiv, musst dir vorstellen, du hast einen Jahrgang
gehabt von Abiturientinnen, die selbst ihre Schulen blockiert haben,
die selbst sehr aktiv unterwegs waren und jetzt in die Hochschulen kommen.
Und die bringen natürlich nochmal ordentlich Power mit rein und das merkst du
jetzt auch, das heißt, jetzt hast du einfach nochmal neue Projekte,
neue Ansätze, sie haben auch gesagt, da wird es jetzt ganz viel kommen,
es wird ein heißer Herbst und plus hast du auch in der Schülernschaft aus meiner Wahrnehmung,
nochmal so ein Empowerment, das heißt, letzten Monat haben wir echt nochmal
da nochmal echt, glaube ich, viel bewegt bei denen, das heißt, du hast auch am 1.
September war der offizielle erste Schultag, haben Schüler zu einer großen Demo
aufgerufen gehabt, der echt sehr, sehr viele Menschen gefolgt sind,
das war echt sehr, sehr beeindruckende Bilder und du hast viele Schulen,
wo einfach Schülern wirklich auch Schulen blockieren.
Das heißt, einfach Unterricht blockiert wird, das heißt angefangen von so kleinen
Aktionen, dass Klassen sich umdrehen, Rücken zum Lehrkraft und denikurieren.
Aber Lehrkräfte noch einmal, die ersetzt wurden.
Das heißt, es wurde tatsächlich Ende August und davor war schon,
aber Ende August war es eine große Welle, hat man unfassbar viele Lehrkräfte
und Schulleitung ersetzt,
und einfach ersetzt durch regimetreue Menschen. Das heißt, jeder,
der bei Demos war, Demos unterstützt hat und so weiter, die wurden im Endeffekt gekündigt.
Und auch das wiederum sehr, sehr rechtswidrig, weil du musst dir vorstellen,
du hast unglaublich viele Menschen, die Lehrkräfte in Serbien sind,
die Zeitverträge haben.
Und laut Recht dürften die eigentlich, ich glaube, es waren maximal zwei Jahre
so einen Zeitvertrag haben, wie so ein KV-Vertrag, so eine Krankheitsvertretung irgendwie.
Und dann musst du eigentlich irgendwann so einen normalen Vertrag angeboten
bekommen. Es gibt auch sowas wie Beamtentum.
Eine Verstetigung.
Genau. Und dass aber Leute, die einfach seit 13 Jahren noch mehr in diesem Zeitvertragsstatus
arbeiten, was natürlich erleichtert, die zu kündigen.
Das heißt, es ist viel, viel leichter, die dann eben loszuwerden.
Und das haben die natürlich jetzt in einer sehr, sehr hohen Zahl gemacht.
Und an manchen Schulen sogar, dass teilweise bis zu 20 Prozent oder über 20
Prozent der Lehrkräfte von anderen weggefallen sind bei einem Bildungswesen,
wo immer weniger Lehrkräfte auf dem Markt stehen.
Das heißt, haben sich immer wenige Menschen eingeschrieben und haben auch für
das Studium, um als Lehrkraft zu arbeiten.
Das heißt, es ist eine Entwicklung der letzten Jahre, die ohnehin schon schwierig
ist. Jetzt gehst du hin und feuerst da brutal viele und du hast gar nichts Personal.
Das heißt, du hast ein Problem, ein Systemproblem, dass du gar nicht die Schulen
erstmal ihren Job machen lassen kannst, selbst wenn du wolltest.
Die wird gar nicht funktionieren, weil einfach Leute fehlen.
Fehlt das Fachpersonal. Zugleich hast du aber Leute, die zu einer Spitze,
die einfach dann nicht akzeptiert werden von den Eltern, von den Schülern, von den Lehrkräften.
Das heißt, du hast also landesweit sehr, sehr unterschiedliche,
aber sehr, sehr krasse Geschichten, die eigentlich da so stattfinden.
Ich habe eine jetzt geteilt gehabt von einem Schulleiter, der sich auf eine
Darmtoilette eingeschlossen hat.
Weil irgendwie dann Schiss hatte wohl vor Lehrkräften und vor Schülern und Eltern, die dastanden.
Und dann kamen Polizeikräfte, die ihn dann von dem Pausengelände raus begleitet haben.
Wir haben ihn dann vom Hof gejagt, weil die einfach gesagt haben,
wir wollen den Schulleiter zurückhaben. Es ist eine relativ große Schule mit
mehreren tausend Schülern.
Also völlig, völlig schräge Geschichten, die da ablaufen. Aber letzten Endes
ist auch das vielleicht so ein Punkt, wenn ich jetzt darauf zu sprechen komme,
wenn man so ein bisschen auf eine Metaebene gehen möchte, wieso die Proteste
so lange zu anhalten sind.
Ich glaube, dass die Studentinnen gelungen ist, durch die Anfangsgeschichte,
die wir letztens mal so ergründet haben,
Eigentlich einen Rahmen zu schaffen, wo vieles, was vorher schon da war,
sich jetzt sammeln konnte.
Das heißt, im Bildungsbereich, ich habe dir gesagt, dass schon viele Probleme
vorliegen und es gab zum Beispiel vor dem Einsturz dieser Geschichte in Novi Sad,
gab es im September davor schon große Proteste im Bildungswesen von Lehrkräften,
massive Proteste, wegen all den Problemen, die ich im Prinzip angesprochen habe,
plus Gehalte, die lächerlich sind und so weiter.
Das heißt, und genauso auch diese Bewegung mit dem Yadar, mit dem Lithium,
dem Bohr vorkommen, gab es auch schon davor Sachen.
Oder das zum Beispiel Gebäude, dieses Projekt, dieses Waterfront Belgrade,
da wurden zum Beispiel auch Sachen, Gebäude.
Rechtswidrig einfach, also von maskierten Menschen einfach eingerissen über
Nacht und auf einmal konnte man da Sachen bebauen.
Also es gab aber schon vorher schon so Aktionen, die zu Initiativen,
teilweise Parteien und Organisationen geführt haben, die so ein Protest irgendwo entstanden ist.
Und letzten Endes hat dieser Protest der Studentinnen, hat dieses,
was zuvor schon stattgefunden hat, gebündelt.
Und darum ist es nicht so, dass man sagen kann, das ist jetzt nur daraus entstanden,
sondern ich würde sagen, es hat einfach so ein Forum geschaffen,
oder auch eine, wo wir Menschen zusammenfinden,
wo das, was zuvor einfach vereinzelt stattgefunden hat, einfach jetzt gebündelt
einfach viel stärker umgesetzt werden.
Die haben einfach verstanden, dass ich jetzt mit meinen Interessen in Bezug
auf Lithium und Bohr, wenn ich jetzt gemeinsam mit Studentinnen und Arbeitern
und zu anderen Interessen gemeinsam auf die Straße gehe, dann bin ich auch bei
meinen Anliegen nicht allein.
Das heißt, dieses Zusammenschließen von verschiedenen Interessen im Sinne von,
lasst uns gucken für ein besseres Land, bessere Gesellschaft, besseren Staat,
hat tatsächlich, glaube ich, dazu geführt, dass du einfach, glaube ich,
diese Kontinuität auf der Proteste hast, weil auch Organisationsstrukturen und
Leute auch ein bisschen und so weiter schon vorher da waren,
sich davor auch schon abgebildet haben.
Eine ähnlich umstrittene Veranstaltung war ja glaube ich die Belgrade Pride.
Man kennt das ja auch schon so aus Ungarn und anderen Ländern,
Minderheiten, macht es sich ja immer gut da ordentlich drauf rumzuhauen,
um die entsprechende, also es ist ja quasi so der CSD, der dann in Belgrad auch
stattfindet, auch schon seit vielen Jahren.
Das war dann auch nochmal eine spezielle Diskussion dieses Jahr oder nicht?
Ja, es waren tatsächlich Leute, Vertreter aus der EU waren da vor Ort und die
finanzieren glaube ich auch gewisse Dinge damit und da gab es eben auch Transparente
mit EU und pro EU und auch Fahnen, ich habe zuerst mal EU-Fahnen gesehen bei der Demo,
und da gab es tatsächlich keine Gewalt,
Übergriffe, das heißt wenn man natürlich jetzt guckt, was so vor passiert ist
kann man sagen, hä, ist ja schräg,
ich habe eigentlich eine Gewalt, die hochgefahren wurde, sie auf der Straße
entladen hat und jetzt bei einer Gruppierung, die eigentlich zuvor viel Gewaltfahrung,
machen musste, habe ich auf einmal keine Gewalt.
Und Polizeischutz wird diskutiert, der Polizeischutz in Demos stellt.
Das muss ich dazu sagen, die Polizei spielt bei Demos gar keine Rolle. Selbst am 15.
März war es zum Beispiel so interessant und bei Demos danach auch,
eigentlich müsste die Polizei ja im Prinzip kontrollieren und Sicherheit gewähren und so weiter.
Die tauchen da nie auf, weil sie eigentlich eine Eskalation wollen.
Die wollen, dass eigentlich Leute irgendwie dann, dass etwas passiert und dann
das Dementsprung auch noch nutzen kann.
Und ich habe jetzt nicht darauf geachtet, ob da Polizei, ich habe jetzt keine
gesehen, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt da war und doch irgendwie geschützt hat,
ich weiß es nicht, auf jeden Fall gab es keine Gewalt.
Das heißt, ich gehe davon aus, dass die Leute, die hätten Gewalt ausüben können,
die vor Gewalt ausüben haben, da zurückgehalten wurden.
Jetzt kann man diskutieren, wieso es so ist. Vielleicht war es auch so,
dass man sagt, okay, in Richtung EU muss man vielleicht auch besänftigen,
weil eben der Budzic auch ein paar, ja.
Harte Aussagen rausgehauen hat, also wie hat man dann EU-Abgeordnete als Abschaum
bezeichnet und sonstige Dinge und kam natürlich nicht so gut an und ich kann
mir jetzt auch vorstellen, das ist vielleicht so ein Sinne von Besänftigung,
also das hatte dieses Spiel zwischen,
ich kommuniziere in EU eine Sache und ich kommuniziere intern was und dann ich
kommuniziere in den USA was, ich kommuniziere nach China was,
das heißt, da kommuniziert er immer, je nachdem mit wem er spricht,
hat er eine andere Wahrheit, die er erzählt,
und konstruiert und deswegen glaube ich war es eben so dieses,
dass man nach außen zeigt schon mal, wir sind noch divers und weltoffen und
bei uns kann man sogar eine Pride durchführen und ohne Probleme und darum war
es tatsächlich innerhalb der LGBTQ-Multivität wohl, da gab es auch Diskussionen,
da teilzunehmen, nicht teilzunehmen und wer teilnimmt, wie man teilnimmt.
Es war so, dass diesmal tatsächlich eben nicht wohl eher so ein Protest war,
das heißt der Kompromiss von den Leuten, die es durchgeführt haben,
haben gesagt, die machen es protestmäßig in Anlehnung des, was gerade stattfindet
und haben auch dann so Reden gehalten und so.
Gab es denn Auseinandersetzungen in den früheren Jahren?
Ja, ja. Also ich glaube die ersten auch, da gab es ja, weiß nicht wie verletzte und so.
Das heißt, ich muss auch zugeben, es ist also, du hast eine massive und eine
sehr starke homophobische Gesellschaft.
Das heißt, du hast also auch alles in die Richtung gehend und das ist tatsächlich
auch so spannend, interessant beim LGBTQ-Thema oder bei der Pride auch.
Es gab ein Posting zum Beispiel, ein Solidaritätsposting von der Fakultät.
Und von einer anderen Fakultät gab es so ein Hates-Posting mit der Thematik
pro Familie, gesunde Familie und so in die Richtung gehend. Das war so eine
christliche Geschichte.
Und dann hat eine Fakultät aufs Novi Sad, ich glaube eine der größten Fakultäten,
wenn nicht die größte glaube ich, die haben so ein Posting, haben gesagt,
schaut, das ist das, was Studentinnen bedeutet.
Weil wenn man von Studentinnen spricht, ist es nicht eine homogene Masse.
Wir sind unfassbar heterogen. Wir haben Leute, die LGBTQ nach vorne tragen.
Wir haben Leute, die etwas sehr christliches Bild nach vorne tragen.
Wir sind sehr, sehr, sehr heterogen. Aber wir wollen das gleiche Ziel.
Wir wollen einen Rechtsstaat. Wir wollen, dass alle Menschen geschützt sind
in diesem Staat. Wir wollen mit eine Demokratie haben.
Und das ist etwas, was mich tatsächlich, fand ich sehr, sehr spannend,
ein Posting von denen, weil es tatsächlich eben so ein Punkt ist,
der häufig diskutiert wird.
Ich poste jetzt mal auch die Studentinnen. Und dann entsteht natürlich auch
bei denen, die bei mir wahrscheinlich mitlesen, so ein Bild von,
das ist eine demokratische, homogene Masse von tollen Menschen. Ist es nicht.
Da sind sicher auch Rechte mit dabei. Da sind verschiedene Gruppierungen mit
dabei. Das ist im Endeffekt einfach ein breites Bild der Gesellschaft.
Nur haben die es geschafft zu sagen, hey, wir sind uns einig,
wir wollen Rechtsstaat haben. Wir wollen eigentlich demokratische Strukturen haben.
Und lass uns darüber streiten, welche inhaltlichen Ziele wir als Gesellschaft
haben wollen. Aber im Diskurs.
Das heißt nicht unter Anwendung von Gewalt zum Beispiel.
Und was jetzt selbst die eine, die dann das stark christliche Bild da gepostet
hat, auch gesagt hat, wir wollen auch, wir sind gegen jede Form von Diskriminierung.
Das heißt, wir haben diese Überzeugung, diese Haltung, aber wir sind nicht für Diskriminierung.
Das heißt, die teilen nicht inhaltlich das, was die sagen, was die machen,
aber trotzdem wollen sie auch nicht, dass Menschen diskriminiert werden.
Deswegen ist es tatsächlich so spannend zu sehen, wie es einfach auch Themen
jetzt auf einmal in der Öffentlichkeit diskutiert werden, die zuvor eigentlich
nie diskutiert wurden oder wenig diskutiert wurden. oder es sehr klar war,
dass wenn medial was diskutiert wird, dann sehr sexistisch, sehr homophob.
Also zum Beispiel auch Frauenrechte oder feministische Akteure,
Kräfte, haben auch wiederum sehr, sehr starke Unterstützung erfahren.
Immer an vielen Stellen wird auch da ein Fokus gelegt und auch gesellschaftlich Debatten angestoßen.
Und zu sagen, hey, wo geht man wie, gegen wen vor?
Also man kann auch schon mit der feministischen Perspektive mal drauf blicken
und wird dann schon feststellen, dass sehr bedeutend häufig und oft.
Gewalt gegen Frauen angewandt wird. Also nicht, dass jetzt Männer nicht verschlagen
wurden und so weiter, aber schon an vielen Stellen merkst du schon auch den
Unterschied von Gewalt, wie sie angewendet wird,
gegen welche Gruppierungen, welche Form von Sexismus und anderen Ismen einfach
da in den Köpfen noch stecken.
Deswegen meine ich von dieser Baustelle, die Gesellschaft nicht noch folgt,
die halt so gewaltig ist.
Ja, das hatten wir eben bei dem Marco Kritschak ja im Prinzip auch schon so.
Genau.
Aber was ist jetzt noch deine These, warum es jetzt bei dieser Belgrade Pride so ruhig geblieben ist?
Es ist irgendwie, weil der unmittelbare Bezug zu den Protesten so nicht da war
und man nicht noch eine andere Baustelle aufmachen wollte,
hatte es vielleicht damit zu tun, dass die EU gerade da eine besondere Aufmerksamkeit drauf hatte.
Vielleicht gar nicht so spezifisch auf die Belgrade Pride, aber diese ganzen
Pride-Veranstaltungen finden ja mehr oder weniger gleichzeitig statt und es
gab ja diese besondere Aufmerksamkeit für die entsprechende CSD-Veranstaltung in Budapest,
wo ja Orban schon seit langer Zeit auf diese Szene einschlägt und entsprechende
Gesetze auch weiter verschärft hat,
um diese Homophobie quasi in der Gesellschaft für seine Zwecke zu nutzen.
Wo ja dann die Stadt selber eingeschritten ist und gesagt hat,
so ja, nee, das ist jetzt hier eine offizielle Veranstaltung der Stadt,
das braucht jetzt gar keine Genehmigung und so weiter.
Und die EU ja dann gesagt hat, so we are watching.
Und dann ist es ja eigentlich relativ easy durchgelaufen und da stellt sich
jetzt für mich eben so die Frage so, spielt die EU eigentlich irgendeine Rolle derzeit?
Ist das komplett außen vor?
Hat Vucic da ein Auge drauf? Ist ihm das eigentlich egal?
Wie passt das zusammen?
Naja, ich habe tatsächlich...
Gestern ein Gedanken gehörte, den ich eigentlich ganz spannend fand in dem Bezug.
Und zwar hat ein Student gesagt, wir diskutieren so viel und so kontrovers und
so heftig über das, was die EU macht oder nicht macht.
Und das zeigt ja, wo wir uns eigentlich sehen.
Das heißt, wenn wir uns da nicht da sehen würden, dann würden wir nicht darüber sprechen.
Dann würden wir darüber sprechen, was Russland macht oder nicht macht oder was auch immer. Oder China.
Das heißt, wir sprechen darüber, wie die EU uns sieht, wo sie eingreift,
wo sie nicht eingreift. und sind ja im Endeffekt Ideen und Erwartungen damit verbunden.
Und deswegen würde ich tatsächlich schon sagen, dass ich glaube,
dass man auf der Suche ist nach dem,
Vorgehen, was ist denn etwas, was sinnvoll wäre. Gestern habe ich eine Dekanin gehört von der.
Politikwissenschaftenfakultät in Belgrad, die hat eben gemeint,
wir dürfen, ihre Strategie fand ich entspannt, habe ich zum ersten Mal so gehört,
wir dürfen nicht zulassen, dass die EU schweigend zuschaut.
Das heißt, Ich kenne tatsächlich von vielen eher so die Haltung,
die gucken ja sowieso nicht, die ignorieren uns ja sowieso, weil die wohl das
Lithium haben für die deutschen Autos und so weiter.
Und die sagt aber, die gibt sich damit nicht zufrieden, sondern sagt,
nee, wir müssen so kommunizieren, dass die nicht mehr wegschauen können.
Das heißt, du musst es denen hinhalten. Und ich fand es tatsächlich auch spannend,
ein anderer Professor hat ihn gesagt, fand ich auch ganz interessant, die Einordnung.
Ich hoffe, dass es immer mehr bei den Leuten ankommt. Der hat gesagt,
hey Leute, was stellt euch denn vor, was die EU ist? Die EU ist doch genauso
wenig homogen, wie wir als Studentinnen oder zivilgesellschaftliche Organisationen.
Wir sind doch genauso mega heterogen.
Und die sind genauso. Das heißt, in der EU gibt es einfach Kräfte,
die definitiv Verbündete sind und versuchen, irgendwas zu verändern.
Und wenn man sich davon abgrenzt, jetzt von der EU, dann schreckt man sich eigentlich
an der Stelle. Das ist ja völlig beknackt eigentlich.
Es wäre viel besser zu sagen, lass doch Verbündete suchen und an der Stelle
das tun, was man tun kann.
Und das ist tatsächlich auch so ein Punkt, jetzt in Verbindung mit dieser Studentinnenliste
und tatsächlich mit dem Vorgehen der Studentinnen, was jetzt ein bisschen kontrovers diskutiert wird.
Das heißt, die haben immer dieses sich distanziert von,
Parteien, distanziert von NGOs, distanziert von allen Organisationen.
Natürlich aus der Lehre der ganzen Organisation, die ich jetzt vorhin angedeutet habe.
Ich habe ja gesagt, dass verschiedene Vorfälle, Proteste, Initiativen ihr habt,
die sie gegründet haben und jedes Mal war die Erfahrung, dass sie unterwandert
wurden von der Opposition, von irgendwelchen Leuten und dann eben erstickt wurden,
durch das Unterwandern.
Und deswegen, aus dieser Lehre haben wir gesagt, wir distanzieren uns erstmal
von allen, aber jetzt kommst du irgendwann an so einen Punkt,
wo du merkst, wenn du jetzt politisch irgendwie den nächsten Schritt gehen willst,
musst du einfach irgendwann Verbündete finden.
Das heißt, du musst auch in der Opposition Verbündete finden und gucken,
wer ist eigentlich dann, wer hat eigentlich welche Richtung schon gearbeitet
und wer ist tatsächlich auf deiner Seite oder auf der Seite der Rechtsstaat
ist oder möchte eine Demokratie haben oder möchte nur die spielen.
Und es ist natürlich, also ich verstehe jetzt nicht beide Seiten,
ich weiß, es ist hochkomplexes, aber zumindest ist für mich schon klar,
dass die sich von allen irgendwie distanzieren.
Hilft die jetzt nicht wirklich beziehungsweise lässt so ein Potenzial da liegen,
um in deiner Sache voranzukommen. Und darum ist es natürlich jetzt schwierig.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sich das entwickeln wird. Ich weiß nicht,
wie die Debatten jetzt geführt werden in den Plenar bei den Studentinnen,
ob man sich da nochmal vielleicht doch irgendwie umentscheidet,
ändert und vielleicht die Strategie wechselt.
Zumindest neben die Zivilgesellschaft und die Professoren, also vor allem die
akademische Gemeinschaft, also
die Professoren und dann haben wir auch ein starkes Netzwerk gegründet.
Ich habe jetzt unterschlagen, im Juni gab es zum Beispiel, Mitte Juni war ich
in Belgrad auch mit zwei meiner Kinder,
da war tatsächlich dann zwei Wochen, da war ich gerade da, haben die eine Hauptkreuzung
in Belgrad blockiert und haben tatsächlich eben das Thema akademisches Netzwerk
aufs Dabro gebracht und die Professorinnen, die haben tatsächlich auch angefangen,
Netzwerk zu gründen, auch international,
bei irgendwelchen Podiumsgesprächen aufzutauchen, Sachen zu erklären,
das heißt, das irgendwo halt eben nochmal ins Fokus zu rücken und zu thematisieren.
Und ich habe tatsächlich gestern nach dem Interview mit einem Dekanen,
hatte ich schon Eindruck, dass sie sehr, sehr geplant und gezielt,
dass sie zu verfolgen werden, auch in Richtung EU.
Dass sie sagen, wir gucken, wo einfach Leute sind und da gehen wir hin.
Und dann werden wir einfach immer wieder sagen, schau hin, schau hin,
schau hin, dass sie nicht mehr wegschauen können.
Und schauen sie auch nicht mehr weg?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich würde tatsächlich diese Idee teilen, dass eben die EU auch im, es gab am 9.
September, glaube ich, gab es diesen Europäischen Parlament so eine Plenarsitzung zum Thema Serbien.
Und da hat man sich so drauf geschaut, wer sagt da was. Und da gab es eben tolle
Re-Beiträge, wo eben auch dann darauf hingewiesen wurde, was in Nobisat passiert ist.
Diese krassen Gewaltexzesse, die es da gab.
Weil tatsächlich an dem Tag auch, das war auch die Zeit von der Pride und so
weiter, auch glaube ich, da waren eben auch EU-Vertreter da,
ich glaube, von den Grünen, Die waren da und die haben das mitbekommen und die
haben dementsprechend das nochmal reingetragen, was sie erlebt haben.
Und dementsprechend hat es da Raum bekommen, dass da Gewalt eskaliert und dass
da einfach Polizeikräfte Dinge tun, die sie nicht tun sollten.
Und dass man als EU-Uner nicht schweigen kann. haben tatsächlich auch Punkte
aufgelistet, was jetzt kommen muss.
Also angefangen haben sie gefordert, dass die, das Bündnis, ich glaube,
EPP, dass die einfach, wo die Partei von Vucic einfach ein Recht hat,
dabei zu sitzen, es kein Stimmrecht hat, aber mitzudenken und sich zu äußern und so weiter,
einfach so integriert wird, dass man diese Position, dass man die verliert,
dass man die ausschließt, das heißt, dass die SNS da nicht dran teilnehmen kann,
die Forderung steht im Raum, wird auch diskutiert und wird auch teilweise auch
eben von Leuten aus den Reihen auch diskutiert.
Dann gab es so Geschichten wie, dass man Delegationen von der EU nach Belgrad,
Serbien schicken möchte, die nochmal mit den Leuten sprechen.
Jetzt kommt wieder diese Geschichte mit der Studentenliste, wieso auch jetzt
manche Professoren dann sagen, ihr müsst die Studentenliste jetzt veröffentlichen,
weil die sagen, wenn EU-Delegierte kommen, dann müsste mit jemandem sprechen können.
Und wenn die halt keine Alternative haben zum Regime, mit wem sollen sie sprechen? Weil die Opposition...
Also mit Studentenliste meinst du, eine Wahlliste für die potenziell auszurufenden Neuwahlen?
Genau. Und das ist das, was natürlich jetzt die jetzt, wo ich sagen würde,
okay, legitimes Argument, kann ich nachvollziehen.
Jetzt muss man gucken, was, welches Gewicht, also was, du hast ein höheres Gewicht,
aber das ist so ein Punkt, der diskutiert wird, zu sagen, wieso man die Liste
jetzt irgendwie kondizieren müsste und also die wollen jetzt wohl irgendwie
nach, haben es schon gesagt, beschlossen, dass sie hinreisen wollen.
Diese ganzen Aussagen wurden aber eigentlich tatsächlich im nächsten Tag kassiert.
Weil eben dann die Rede von allein war und die einfach...
Nicht ein Wort Serbien erwähnt hat. Und das kam auch hier medial an.
Das heißt, hier sage ich es, haben ihn Serbien an.
Das heißt, die haben das sehr wohl wahrgenommen im Endeffekt nach dem Motto,
guck da, also man muss gucken, was sie sagt und wenn sie Serbien nicht mehr
erwähnt, dann ist das, was im Endeffekt die harten Fakten aktuell darstellt.
Und das andere wird im Endeffekt nur Lippenbekenntnisse sein oder da wirst du
jetzt nicht wirklich was, auf die musst du jetzt nicht setzen, so in die Richtung.
Und ich muss tatsächlich sagen, was man vielleicht wissen muss,
also falls jemand sich anhören sollte und so weit noch jetzt immer noch mithören
sollte, die lesen sehr genau mit, was die internationale Presse schreibt.
Das heißt, ob jetzt Deutschland, Amerika oder wer auch immer,
das Land auch immer, was über Serving geschrieben wird, wird sehr wohl da wahrgenommen
und dementsprechend auch dann kommuniziert.
Und darum ist natürlich jeder Beitrag, der zum Beispiel auch kritisch erscheint
über das Regime, der wird da auch ausgestrahlt, diskutiert.
Und wiederum setzt zum Beispiel politischen Druck, erhöht den politischen Druck auf dieses Regime.
Weil natürlich dann wiederum eben der Vucic dieses Spiel, was er spielt,
eben so nicht spielen kann.
Das heißt, alles, was das demaskiert, dieses Märchen, was er erzählt,
trägt dazu bei, dass er einfach dann.
An verschiedensten Bereichen Dinge verliert. Also unter anderem natürlich auch,
was man auch gefordert hat, damals bei diesem Europäischen Parlament,
dass man gesagt hat, dass man prüft, wo die Gelder, dass man vielleicht auch
Gelder stoppt, weil er die auch EU-Gelder beziehen.
Ja, aktuell schon, es gibt verschiedene Töpfer wohl, die auf diese Gelder beziehen,
für verschiedene Projekte.
Und dass man sagt, hey, dass man diese Gelder stoppt, und bis man geprüft hat
und prüfen kann, wo die Gelder hinfließen.
Nach dem Motto, das wäre eigentlich eine ganz sinnvolle Idee,
zu sagen, du stoppst diese EU-Gelder, bis Neuwahlen ausgeschrieben sind.
Und dann will ich auch dann eben sagen, okay, jemand handhabt mit dem Geld auf
eine legitime Art und Weise, weil aktuell ist es wohl nicht gegeben.
Oder wie auch immer. Das heißt, du hast keinen Rechtsstaat, hast keine Transparenz,
kannst nicht nachvollziehen, wer welche Gelder einsetzt.
Ja, also das Thema ist sicherlich nicht oben auf der Liste, aber es bringt auf
jeden Fall etwas, wenn sich die EU mit Serbien beschäftigt.
Das lese ich da jetzt mal raus.
Jetzt gab es ja noch ein paar andere Ereignisse glaube ich rund um diese Basketball EM, die gerade,
stattgefunden hat, die Deutschland ja gewonnen hat, Serbien ist glaube ich,
spielt Basketball auch eine relativ große Rolle Jaja.
Es ist schon auch so ein Basketball Land, also es ist auch Basketball,
Fußball, es gibt so verschiedene Sportarten, also Sport an sich hat ein sehr
hohes Ansehen in Serbien,
und Und es ist so gewesen, dass eine Gruppe von, wiederum,
es gibt Namen, die im Netz kursieren, die relativ schnell ausfindig gemacht,
eine kleine Gruppe von bezahlten Schlägertruppen nach Riga geflogen ist,
um da eben serbische Fans, die im TV auftauchen, davon abzuhalten,
irgendwelche Dinge zu skadieren, die Anti-Budic, Anti-Budic-Regime sind.
Und die in den Vaterschläge gedroht haben und teilweise auch die angegangen
haben. und das war natürlich etwas, was natürlich im Ideal in Serbien diskutiert
wurde und dann gab es eben, als sie ausgeschieden sind aus der EM,
Was auch wiederum ein Skandal war für Serbien, dass der EM so früh ausgeschieden,
weil sie eigentlich für die, klar war, sie Gold gewinnen werden.
Dann war es dann so, dass in Belgrad gab es ein Spiel von Serbien gegen England,
eine Nationalmannschaft, Fußball.
Und da gab es wiederum so Anti-Vucic-Sprechchöre, die tatsächlich bei vielen,
Sportbereichen, auch jetzt Basketball, Fußball mittlerweile echt Usus sind, auch in kleinen Ligen,
dass dann eben dann Leute wieder auf die Menschen los sind und auf die eingeschlagen haben.
Und man muss dazu sagen, man hat dann diese Bilder wieder im Netz kursiert,
man hat dann relativ schnell festgestellt, es war die gleiche Truppe, die in Riga war.
Was wiederum eben dann daraus einige schließen kann.
Das heißt, zum einen kann man daraus schließen, dass scheinbar die Gruppe,
die bereit ist, Gewalt anzuwenden für eine Summe X, schrumpft.
Das heißt, wenn man so jetzt die letzten Monate so sich anschaut,
auch bei den ganzen Protesten, wir haben jetzt eine Sache noch nicht angesprochen,
die Antiproteste, also die Antiprotest-Proteste, also überall was organisiert,
dieses Regime, kommen immer weniger Menschen hin.
Entweder, ich kann es so erklären, ist es, also entweder wahrscheinlich und,
und, und, und, das heißt einen Widerstand im System, das heißt,
dass Menschen zum Beispiel nicht mehr bereit sind, das zu tun, was er möchte.
Du hast im Endeffekt auch wahrscheinlich, glaube ich, auch eine finanzielle
Frage, dass einfach das alles sehr, sehr teuer ist, über viele Monate auch dann
diese Menschen zu bezahlen, da hinzugehen, Sachen zu demonstrieren und Sachen
zu sagen, die sie sagen sollen.
Plus, du hast natürlich immer ganz proaktiv auch Widerstände,
die wachsen innerhalb von Systemen, das heißt, einfach Leute,
zum Beispiel bei Polizeikräften, gibt es so einen stillen Widerstand,
wo dann Leute sich massenhaft haben krankschreiben lassen.
Wo sie wussten, wo man wusste, dass sie eingesetzt werden, gegen die Zivilbevölkerung zum Beispiel.
Es gibt tatsächlich so verschiedenste, oder zum Beispiel jetzt wurde eine Spezialeinheit
wie GSG 9, wo der Chef wurde auch abgesetzt und jetzt gegen neue Personen ausgetauscht.
Und das ist jemand, der ein sehr hohes Ansehen in Serbien hat,
sehr professioneller Typ und der hat zum Beispiel auch sehr offen,
der hat sehr deutlich gesagt,
dass er abgesetzt wurde, weil er eben, weil er wurde gesagt,
er kann an den Spitzen dieser ganzen Organisation, kann er es nicht leisten,
Leute zu haben, die nicht das tun, was er sagt.
Und das hat er sehr oft in den Medien kompliziert, was natürlich dem Regime
auch nicht so gefallen hat.
Aber letztendlich dieses Sport-Event, du siehst, also da steigt der Widerstand,
lässt sich der Widerstand spüren, bei auch Konzerten und Musikfestivals,
also auch Musikbranche genauso.
Das heißt, es gibt SängerInnen, oder die dieses Regime unterstützen und dazu
beitragen, die werden boykottiert.
Entweder pauchen Leute auf und so ein Gegenkonzert, super laut,
bis über zum einen Mal, letztes Mal haben sie jetzt tatsächlich die Konzertkarten
gekauft und haben es dann einfach unterwandert und da ist die Sängerin gar nicht erst aufgetreten,
ist dann nach Hause gefahren, weil die einfach eben Slogans skandiert haben,
Anti-Budget-Regime-Slogans skandiert haben.
Das heißt, man merkt einfach, das, was ich beim letzten Podcast,
wo ich geändert bin mit, die lassen nicht zu, dass sie ihren Alltag haben,
das wurde konsequent durchgeführt in allen Bereichen, ob jetzt Sport,
Musik, egal wo du unterwegs bist.
Menschen halten dir das jetzt vor die Augen.
Genauso auch die Leute, die neutralen Leute, das heißt die, die in den Cafés
sitzen, die werden auch immer heftig und laut diskutiert, dass man sagt,
wie kannst du im Café sitzen, wie wir nebenan demonstrieren,
während mein Kind da auf der Straße verschlagen wird und du da sitzt,
dein Käffchen trinkst und du tust, als würde es nichts angehen.
Und das ist auch wiederum eine Debatte. Das heißt, du merkst, dass du
Also dieses, bist du Teil davon? Oder muss ich jetzt positionieren?
Hilfst du jetzt mit, dass wir die Sache jetzt zu Ende bekommen oder nicht?
Und dieser Druck wird tatsächlich schon, habe ich den Eindruck,
auf allen Seiten von allen Leuten einfach noch stärker erhöht, erhöht, erhöht.
Deswegen habe ich tatsächlich auch das Gefühl, auf der einen Seite das Gefühl, es müsste bald enden.
Auf der anderen Seite sind die Ressourcen natürlich immer noch extrem groß.
Und die macht es extrem groß.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie lange es sich halten wird. Ich weiß noch nicht,
ob es zu weiteren Eskalationen kommen wird.
Ich finde es super schwierig, einzuordnen, was als nächstes kommen wird.
Die Einzige, wo ich sicher bin, ist, dass es hier kein Zurück gibt,
dass die Menschen hier nicht nachlassen.
Wenn auf allen Ebenen des Engagements, ob es jetzt in beruflichen Kontexten ist,
dass ich innerhalb der beruflichen Kontexte, dass zum Beispiel Medizinerinnen,
also ich habe jetzt ganz, ganz viele Branchen auch, wo wieder Menschen anfangen
zu streiken, auf die Straße gehen, Druck ausüben.
Also in allen Bereichen sehe ich so, dass wieder Menschen jetzt Gas geben,
jetzt im Herbst und mal gucken, wozu das führt.
Ein anderer Name, der noch viel im Rahmen der Proteste ist, der glaube ich von
Bogdan Jovicic, der spielte nochmal eine bestimmte Rolle, was ist da die Geschichte dahinter?
Ja.
Und der wurde im Zuge der Proteste im August, glaube ich, wurde er festgenommen.
Das ist der Weg, glaube ich, über 1.000 Festnahmen gehabt. Ich glaube,
im Laufe der Proteste gab es noch eine Zahl, die veröffentlicht wurde.
Über 1.000 Festnahmen, aber tatsächlich ohne eine Beweislast zu haben.
Das heißt, die Leute, die Prozedere sind immer das Gleiche.
Du verhaftest Menschen, setzt sie in 30 Tagen in Untersuchungshaft und dann
in der Regel gehen die hin und verlängern die Untersuchungshaft nochmal.
Weil die Gerichte
ihren Job nicht machen an manchen Stellen tatsächlich gelingt es wiederum mit
Gerichten ihren Job machen und der Widerstand wächst auch da und Anwälten eben
dann doch die Leute aus der U-Haft irgendwie freizubekommen dass sie zumindest
dann aus dem Haus aus dem Hausarrest heraus sich verteidigen das gelingt an manchen Stellen,
aber ihm ist tatsächlich nicht so gelungen das heißt er war 30 Jahre U-Haft
hat sie 30 Tage U-Haft Hat dann gesagt, dass er sich eigentlich friedlich verhalten hat,
in der Hoffnung, dass er dann eben nach diesen 30 Tagen vielleicht Hausarrest
bekommt und dann daraus sich irgendwie verteidigt.
Ist nicht so der Fall gewesen. Das heißt, die haben tatsächlich dann ihm nochmal
weitere 30 Tage angelastet und dann gesagt, jetzt tritt er in Hungerstreik und
hat dann einen Brief veröffentlicht und hat es angekündigt und gesagt,
und dieser Brief und diese Ankündigung, dass es in Hungerstreik tritt,
wurde versucht eben zu vertuschen.
Das heißt, die Behörden haben versucht, es eben nicht nach außen dringen zu
lassen. Seine Anwalt hat es dann trotzdem erfahren, fünf Tage später.
Oder mehrere Tage später, wenn es fünf Tage waren. Und tatsächlich dann eben
auch, sein Vater ist in der Zwischenzeit verstorben und das hat er auch nicht erfahren.
Seine Mutter durfte ihn nur einmal die Woche besuchen und dementsprechend verzögert,
ob er fünf Tage später erfahren hat, dass sein Vater gestorben ist von der Mutter.
Und dann war es dann so, dass er zur Beerdigung, ob er gehen darf,
nicht gehen darf, war bis zur letzten Sekunde nicht klar und dann haben sie
ihn doch zur Beerdigung gehen lassen,
aber dann tatsächlich nur die letzte Minute von der Beerdigung wurde er hingebracht
und dann mit Fußfesseln und drei Polizeikräften nebendran.
Ja, und der hat dann, ich weiß nicht, danach war dann, glaube ich,
die Geschichte, also die Bilder haben sich dann kursiert im Netz.
Danach wurde er irgendwie, weil er in einem körperlichen Zustand nachgelassen
hat, ins Militärgefängnis gebracht, nach Belgrad.
Und ich glaube, da ist er jetzt noch. Und jetzt sind tatsächlich auch wieder
massive Proteste landesweit gewesen, wo Leute eben sich mit ihm solidarisieren.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass zum Beispiel dieses, ich habe es an vielen Stellen
jetzt nicht gesagt, gibt es einige Punkte, die man noch beleuchten könnte,
auf eine Metaperspektive, auch Strategiewechsel zum Beispiel,
auch dass man gesagt hat, dieses Solidarisieren.
Das heißt, du hast eine Sache in einer Stadt etwas und ein ganzes Land sind
gegen Leute auf die Straße. Das heißt, dass immer klar ist, du bist nicht allein.
Das ist auch so eine zentrale Botschaft. Du bist nicht allein. Wir sind bei dir.
Und das ist etwas, was sich gewandelt hat in den letzten Monaten,
dass auch teilweise auch Städte zu Städte fahren.
Das heißt, Zivilgesellschaft zu Zivilgesellschaft fährt. Also zum Beispiel,
wo dann auch dann die Jugendlichen verprügelt worden sind, wie ich vorhin erzählt habe.
Es sind auch von anderen Städten Leute hingefahren, auch von Ujicic zum Beispiel,
auch sind Leute hingefahren, haben solidarische Meerschwinden gemeinsam gemacht.
Das heißt, man rückt zusammen als Land, auch mit den Bränden und so,
aber auch die Botschaft, die gesagt hat, pass auf, niemand ist allein.
Wir haben zwar keinen Staat, der funktioniert und für uns da ist, aber wir haben uns.
Und das finde ich eine ziemlich starke Botschaft. Ich glaube,
etwas, was auch dieses alles immer so trägt,
dass man eben diese Solidarität erfahren hat und die, glaube ich,
mit Leuten etwas macht, was eben wiederum im Transformationsprozess,
Wenn man davon ausgeht, was gesellschaftlich ansteht, glaube ich,
ein großes Potenzial ist, dass man eben Empathie hat,
solidarisch ist und einfach weiß, was es bedeutet, dass man den Stellen,
wie es einem schwer geht, einfach erlebt, dass Menschen für einen da sind,
Menschen, die man nicht kennt, Menschen aus anderen Städten.
Ja, wo sind wir jetzt?
Also das waren glaube ich im Wesentlichen so die Ereignisse,
die jetzt so in den letzten fünf Monaten das Geschehen geprägt haben.
Was siehst du jetzt sozusagen, was ist so dein Zwischenstand?
Ich meine, das floss natürlich jetzt zwischen den Zeilen schon ganz gut heraus,
aber wo siehst du die Proteste?
Haben die noch genug Energie? Wackelt das Regime?
Braucht es mehr internationalen Einfluss?
Ist es sozusagen kurz vorm Ende?
Ich weiß, es ist unmöglich in die Zukunft zu schauen.
In der Zeit kann wieder was anderes passieren, aber vielleicht mal so ein Take auf den Status Quo.
Also ich würde sagen, dass die Erkenntnis sich in der breiten Bevölkerung mittlerweile gesetzt hat.
Deswegen hatte ich anfangs mal gesagt, dass der Weg sich mittlerweile etabliert
hat zu sagen, ich versuche über die bestehenden Strukturen Macht wieder zu erlangen.
Ich glaube, dass sich die Erkenntnis gesetzt hat, dass es über Demos allein,
nicht kippen wird. Das heißt, die Demos brauchst du für dich.
Die haben andere Funktionen als am Anfang, glaube ich.
Am Anfang hatten die Dämoni die Funktion von, du zeigst, dass Legitivität nicht
vorliegt für das Regime.
Dann hatten sie eine Funktion von Solidarität. Und jetzt gibt es tatsächlich
andere, verschiedenste Funktionen. Teilweise auch Informationen.
Das heißt, über Leute auch aufzuklären. Deswegen auch dieser Podcast,
den sie gestartet haben, die Studentinnen, finde ich, das ist ja auch super clever.
Das haben sie auch als Aktionsform immer wieder gemacht. Dass sie gesagt haben,
dass sie immer wieder so Aktionen hatten, wo einfach die aufgeklärt wurde,
über welche Probleme einfach vorliegen und welche Probleme Korruption oder das
ganze korrupte System eigentlich verursacht.
Und jetzt haben die den Podcast einfach nochmal ein Format geschaffen,
wo Leute über ein bis zwei Stunden explizit eine Thematik aufgreifen und dann
als Expertin eben dann den Leuten zugänglich machen und verständlich machen.
Und ich glaube, diese Strategie zu sagen, wir müssen uns als Gesellschaft verstehen,
wo möglichst alle gut informiert sind, wo möglichst alle laut mitdenken,
miteinander im Diskurs sind.
Und ich glaube, das ist eine Strategie, die Sie gerade verfolgen,
auch die Zivilgesellschaft selbst, dass man einfach so verstanden hat,
es wird jetzt nicht morgen enden und wenn es jetzt selbst morgen enden würde,
müssen wir uns für das nächste danach irgendwie uns auch vorbereiten.
Deswegen lass uns doch mal irgendwie einen anderen Weg beschreiten.
Lass uns mal gucken, wie wir einfach gemeinsam schlau werden als Gesellschaft.
Und lass uns mal gucken, welche Strukturen wo vorliegen und was man da im Prinzip machen könnte.
Und ich weiß nicht, es ist natürlich jetzt, es klingt immer so,
als gäbe es so einen, diesen einen Plan und einen so ein Mastermind.
Aber letztendlich sind es einfach hochkomplexe gesellschaftliche Systeme,
soziale Systeme, wo einfach so viele Parameter einwirken, dass man einfach nicht
absehen kann, in welche Richtung sich was entwickelt.
Ich glaube noch aber trotzdem, dass aufgrund der Werte, die sie bisher vor sich
her getragen haben, dass es Potenzial ist, dass es in eine gute Richtung sich
entwickelt, weil ich glaube, diese Werte sind die Leitplanken und der Kompass von allem, was kommt.
Wenn sie sich an diesen Werten weiter dran orientieren und sagen,
Solidarität, Empathie, Gewaltfreiheit, Gegendiskriminierung und so weiter.
Diskussionen, Beteiligungsprozesse und so weiter. Wenn sie daran festhalten,
dass es das, was mir Hoffnung gibt, dann glaube ich, dass es sich in eine gute
Richtung entwickeln kann.
Wenn aber jetzt an irgendeiner Stelle irgendwas kippen sollte und diese Werte
nicht mehr als Leitplanken fungieren,
dann glaube ich, kann sich einfach in eine völlig andere Richtung entwickeln.
Die Gefahr sehe ich immer, weil eben, wie gesagt, soziale, komplexe Systeme,
Menschen können teilweise gut manipulieren, was die Vergangenheit oder die Geschichte gezeigt hat.
Deswegen, ich kann es nicht absehen. Auch jetzt mit Social Media,
also tatsächlich, Social Media spielt eine massive, krasse, krasse Rolle bei der ganzen Bewegung.
Wenn das zum Beispiel sich drehen würde, also wenn da jetzt irgendwie Verbote
kommen würden, aber vielleicht auch in Absprache mit irgendwelchen,
Instagram ist zum Beispiel echt so ein zentrales Ding.
Also wenn du zum Beispiel Instagram irgendwie da einstellen würdest,
hättest du ein Problem. Als Beispiel.
Oder andere Messenger-Dienste. Das heißt, es gibt schon so verschiedene Dinge,
wo ich immer denke, was machst du da? Und du musst irgendwie einen Plan B haben.
Ich habe tatsächlich auch, aber deswegen finde ich, dass sie eigentlich ganz
clever machen, weil sie ich glaube, es ist sehr komplex, die gehen aus verschiedenen
strategischen Richtungen.
Also zum Beispiel haben sie angefangen auch im Print vorzukommen.
Die haben mit Zeitungen, Kooperationen, es gibt eine Zeitung,
so ein Wochenmagazin, wo sie immer die studentische Stimme gehört wird.
Dann den Podcast, dann hast du dieses Student in jedem Dorf.
Das heißt, die haben schon verschiedene Strategien, die sie eigentlich fahren,
um möglichst viel in Dialog zu treten, möglichst viel ihrer Stimme und eine
gut durchdachte Stimme im Prinzip sichtbar zu machen, Menschen zu informieren
und zu befähigen, überhaupt dann vielleicht morgen, um eine gute Entscheidung treffen zu können.
Deswegen, ich finde tatsächlich, dass sie bisher strategisch eigentlich ziemlich
viel richtig machen, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Und ich hoffe nur, dass die anderen Kräfte, also auch zum Beispiel die akademische
Vereinigung, das Netzwerk, die Professorinnen, die sehr, sehr laut werden,
zum Beispiel auch sehr laut werden mit der Forderung, dass die Liste veröffentlicht werden soll.
Bin ich, sehe ich es eher skeptisch und bin ich eher kritisch,
weil ich immer denke, ich verstehe aus der Position dieser Professoren,
des Professors und so weiter und
Dekanen, wie auch immer, verstehe ich die Intention und die, die dahinter.
Aber bei den Studenten ist immer diese Maschinerie dahinter, dieses Plenum.
Das heißt, wie eine Entscheidung getroffen wird, es basiert immer auf diesem
kollektiven Prozess, wo einfach multiple Perspektiven berücksichtigt werden.
Und deswegen vertraue ich auf diese Lösungen, weil ich weiß,
dass einfach vieles berücksichtigt wurde, dass an einem Stelle von einer Person
von einem kleinen Kreis eben nicht berücksichtigt wurde.
Und deswegen glaube ich tatsächlich, ich würde an der Stelle eher gucken,
dass man weiterhin die Studentinnen und diese Prozesse unterstützt und zum Beispiel
auch ihnen die Zeit gibt. Also ich habe jetzt ein bisschen auch Respekt vor dem neuen Semester.
Das heißt, wenn die jetzt wirklich die Idee haben sollten, die Professorin,
die ich teilweise schon gehört habe, ja, jetzt machen wir normale Lehre mit
aber noch Add-on-Proteste.
Das heißt, Blockaden soll es vielleicht nicht mehr geben, aber lass uns doch
einfach dann irgendwie Zeit zur Verfügung stehen, wo ihr weiter die Proteste organisieren könnt.
Das wäre, glaube ich, eine fatale Entscheidung, weil der Faktor Zeit ist eigentlich
tatsächlich das gewesen, was das alles erst ermöglicht hat.
Und wenn du in den Zeit raubst, dann wird, ob es jetzt diese Prozesse sind,
die du brauchst, um eine gute Entscheidung zu finden, bist du über andere Sachen, ja.
Aber wenn du in die Zeit ihn raubst, dann nimmst du etwas, was Wesentliches, was Tragendes.
Ja, und irgendwann wird es ja ohnehin Wahlen geben müssen. Daher wird sich,
glaube ich, auch Vucic nicht vordrücken können.
Ja, Delian, ich sag mal, jetzt haben wir es erstmal wieder ganz gut zusammengefasst, oder?
Richtig. Ich glaube, ein Punkt, den wir dann wahrscheinlich nächstes Mal vielleicht,
falls es nächstes Mal geben sollte, diskutieren werden, ist dann,
was ist am 1. November passiert.
Das heißt, es nähert sich der Jahrestag und darauf blicken jetzt alle,
was wird da wohl passieren.
Es gibt so verschiedene Erzählungen, dass die Studenten wohl planen,
da auch wieder so Protestmärsche nach Nobisat zu machen aus allen Richtungen
von allen Stadtteilen aus, um da eine große Demo durchzuführen.
Zeitgleich streut das Regime wieder Gerüchte, dass es da zu Gewalt kommen wird.
Natürlich seitens der Studentinnen aus russischen Quellen, von der russischen,
wurde natürlich geleakt,
weiß, dass sie da so irgendwelche Terroranschläge weiß nicht,
was da geplant ist, also letzten Endes wieder die gleiche Maschinerie wie sonst
halt auch immer, aber deswegen, ich glaube der 1.
November wird auch nochmal ein spannendes Datum sein, weil einfach nochmal,
wenn man so sieht, ein Jahr ist jetzt dann vorbei, ein Jahr ist immer noch niemand
richtig zur Rechenschaft gezogen worden, es liegt immer noch keine Transparenz vor,
wer, wo, wer, wie verantwortlich war, wie es dazu kommen konnte,
aber in der Zwischenzeit über tausend Menschen verhaftet, teilweise rechtswidrig,
ohne irgendwelche Belege und Beweise.
Das heißt, diese Ungerechtigkeit und diese Klarheit in der Sachlage,
ich glaube tatsächlich, dass die von Tag zu Tag zunimmt und dementsprechend
ich fühle zumindest, ich habe das Gefühl, dass das Ende naht,
aber die Gefühle täuschen.
Wie gesagt, jetzt sage ich das, ich bin beziehungsweise morgen,
was würde ich anderes sagen, würde?
Ja, du hast in einem Post irgendwie die Star Wars Serie Andor zitiert.
Ich übersetze das mal so frei. Tyrannei erfordert ständige Anstrengungen.
Sie bricht, sie wird undicht.
Autorität ist zerbrechlich. Unterdrückung ist die Maske der Angst.
Eine einzige Sache wird die Belagerung brechen. Merkt euch das und versucht es.
Witzigerweise habe ich das gepostet und ein paar Wochen später,
Monate später, habe ich Nobisat eine Wand gesehen, auf die das geschrieben wurde.
Oh.
Ja, da dachte ich, wow.
Na, siehst du mal. Na gut, also wenn jetzt die Studenten sogar schon einen Podcast
gestartet haben, dann ist es ja eigentlich bald vorbei mit der Regierung,
weil wir wissen ja, nichts hat so viel Power wie ein Podcast.
Absolut, absolut.
Ich sage vielen Dank für deinen Beitrag.
Genau, und ich sage auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei UKW.
Ja, schreibt euch ruhig mal bei uns in die Kommentare rein, wie wir das hier
fortsetzen sollen und dann hören wir uns vielleicht bald wieder und bis dahin
sage ich Tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.